Ja, ich war gemutet, das ist richtig, aber ich war absichtlich gemutet.
Zeit für RTX On.
Ja, das habe ich verpasst, die Vorstellung von einem neuen Nvidia Zeug.
Habe ich überhaupt nicht mehr dran gedacht.
Wann war das? Letzten Dienstag, ne?
Ich habe irgendwann 21 Uhr auf die Uhr gekommen und habe gesagt, oh, ist jetzt vorbei.
Aber ich muss sagen,
ähm, was die, also die haben ja
3000, also ich bin ja bei der Benahmung wieder ein bisschen blickig.
Irgendwie ein bisschen komisch, ne?
Von 1080 Ti, 2280 Ti
auf eine 3080 Ti
gibt es nicht und eine 3090 und
Alter, was auch immer.
Zumindest wird es teuer.
Dafür wird die mittlere Klasse schneller als die alte High-End-Klasse
und kostet nur die Hälfte.
Ja.
Stripes 007, 14 Monate.
Oh, excellent subscription.
Warte mal hier, das ist ja schon richtig.
Und der Easy-Killer auch, 11 Monate.
Das ist ganz knapp noch, ganz knapp, nur, nur.
Aber bald ist es.
Die RTX 3080 soll doppelt so schnell sein.
Ja gut, die erzählen viel, wenn der Tag lang ist, mal abwarten.
Aber ich werde mir auf jeden Fall,
wenn das jetzt, wenn das denn erhältlich sein wird,
irgendwann dieses Jahr noch,
also offiziell schon, aber
wir wissen ja, wie das ist, wenn die noch nicht.
Wir wissen ja, wie das ist, wenn die noch nicht.
Und wenn es neue Hardware rauskommt,
das ist erst mal vorbestellt und danach ist es ausverkauft.
Dann wahrscheinlich kriegst du erst wieder im Februar
und die Grafikkarte.
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch AMD.
Äh.
4.5.
Leak has appeared.
Das haben wir schon mal angeguckt.
Nutzt du irgendwelche Nvidia-eigene Sachen?
Äh, hä, was?
So was wie, äh, nö, nö.
Das liegt aber, also RTX Voice und so verwende ich nicht.
Ich hab's mir noch nicht mal angeguckt.
Ich muss sagen, ich find das Setup so jetzt ganz okay aus
und bin nicht zu faul, da dran rumzubasteln.
Solange das funktioniert, ist es okay.
Ja doch, Shadowplay, Shadowplay, klar.
Shadowplay verwende ich oft.
Kann man schon vorbestellen?
Kann man schon irgendwie vorbestellen oder so?
Wir verraten euch jetzt schon,
wo ihr die, wo ihr sie vorbestellen...
Äh, nein.
Warum ist das so teuer?
Ja.
What the fuck?
Warum ist das eine 2080 Ti so teuer?
Und was ist das da nebendran?
GTF?
Ah, nee, RTX.
Das ist ja keine GTX, das ist ja RTX.
Nee, gibt's doch nicht.
Okay.
Oh, guck mal.
Bunte iGame.
Na, wenn die bunt ist,
dann ist ja alles gut.
Und da ist die oben...
Ach, das ist eine Wasserkühlung, verstehe.
Ups.
Gearbest China Shop, ja.
Ich glaube, ich würde auch gerade
3000 Euro im China Shop ausgeben.
Der größte...
Ja, Herz 390, da gebe ich dir teilweise recht.
Er schreibt, der größte Vorteil
von Nvidia ist der Nvidia Codec.
AMD hat ja was ähnliches, aber das funktioniert
nicht so gut. Aber was man nicht
vergessen darf, dass einfach die schnellsten Karten
von Nvidia kommen. Das ist natürlich auch ein Vorteil.
Mag jetzt vielleicht
kein krasses Feature sein,
aber einfach die schnellsten, schnellere
Grafikkarten haben wir ja auch nicht verkehrt.
Was kostet denn der Kram, wenn es rauskommt?
1500 oder sowas, ne?
Irgendwie sowas
in dem Dreh.
PC-Magazin,
da hatte ich auch mal früher ein paar Ausgaben gekauft.
So ein Crap. Das war genauso mies...
Nein, okay, nee, PC-Welt war schlechter.
Wurde nur noch getoppt von einem vollen Computerbild.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
PC-Games-Hardware, den traue ich immer.
Ja, was soll's denn kosten?
Preis? Preis?
Seht ihr irgendwo den Preis?
Ah, hier.
Ich...
WTF? Sag mir einfach, was Nvidia gesagt hat.
Ich glaub 1400,
ja, 1500.
Hier sonst offiziell.
Okay, exzellent.
Pounders Edition.
Pack W.
Ah, exzellent.
Erhältlich ab
24.9. Ist gar nicht mehr so lang hin.
Also Leute,
wenn ich mir...
Das Dumme ist, ja,
ich würde mir gerne einen komplett neuen PC kaufen.
Dazu fehlen
mir aber
die CPU.
Eine ordentliche.
Eine neue
Ryzen-Generation. So.
Und...
Ich überleg mir, ob ich mir jetzt schon eine 3090
kaufe und in den alten PC einbaue.
Die Sache ist nämlich
die, mein aktueller Rechner ist ja
schnell genug.
Ist ja nicht so, als bräuchte ich über...
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn ich mir
einen neuen Rechner kaufe,
der wird in Spielen nicht
selbst,
selbst wenn AMD
jetzt irgendwann noch Ende des Jahres
einen Ryzen
4950X rausbringt.
Gehen wir mal von aus, der ist, keine Ahnung.
Jetzt sind wir mal optimistisch und sagen,
der ist 20% schneller als der alte.
Dann ist das immer noch plus minus
paar Prozent, was man über
takteter 8700K aktuell
in Spielen macht.
Ich brauch die Performance nur für Spiele,
weil rendern ist schnell genug.
Auch mit 6-Kern.
Ich rendere ein Video für YouTube
upscaled.
Also, wenn ich das upscale
auf 4K,
weil mehr Bitrate auf YouTube,
rendere ich das knapp in der Laufzeit
von dem Video. Also, da kann man sich echt
nicht beschweren.
Einfach, weil es geht. Ja, genau.
Aber dazu müsste erstmal AMD
beikommen mit den CPUs.
Naja.
Wenn ich denn mal YouTube-Video rendere.
Ja, habt ihr recht.
Exposed, Alter.
Exposed.
Dann kann ich 8K hochladen, ja.
Ja, gut. Also.
Also, wenn schon, kaufe ich mir so eine.
Allerdings wird's
wahrscheinlich sein wie immer, dass die hier
deutlich besser
zu bekommen ist.
Wo ist eigentlich der Sinn davon, dass das vorher
rauskommt als das?
Ja, dass man zwei Wochen Marketing-Hype hat.
Moin, Soft Jelly.
Ey, dieser
komische Song, der ist auch überall dabei.
Egal, welcher Playliste.
Fange zum Wintersemester an, Software-Entwicklung
zu studieren. Irgendwelche Tipps?
Ja, sich jetzt schon ein paar Programmiersprachen anzugucken
und so die Base, die Basics
anzueignen.
Nein, das kaufen wir jetzt garantiert
nicht mehr.
Ja, also dann, sowas da.
Allerdings wird man die nicht bekommen, es sei denn,
es sei denn, man
setzt sich, ich weiß ja nicht, wann die das
shoppen.
Es sei denn, man setzt sich
hier hin, um 0 Uhr
und bestellt eine vor.
Dieses TM, Alter.
Die machen immer einfach mal mehr TM hin, dass
keiner irgendwann sagen kann nach dem Motto, ah, war nicht
geschützt, lul.
Was wollt ihr mit bunte iGame?
China Shops.
Kann man die China Shops einfach mal wegfiltern?
Da haben doch bestimmt schon
irgendwelche unseriösen Anbieter
den Kram gelistet, hä?
Nee.
Naja, wurscht.
Aber,
da wird's mal echt Zeit.
Neue Hardware, ich brauch den Kram jetzt mal langsam
her.
Auf Banggood und AliExpress bestimmt.
Ich bekomm bald eine Lieferung
von Banggood.
Auf Guides halt
ist gelistet, okay.
Was soll da RTX Ultimate
und RTX Premium sein?
Ach, das ist irgend so ein Asus
fertig Ding mit Custom Kühler
und vielleicht ein bisschen ab Werk
übertaktet oder so.
Na gut, aber die gibt's ja noch nirgendswo.
Ist aber ganz schön alt, 1976.
Äh,
Z-Pudding, 7 Monate.
Excellent Subscription.
Kaufst du dann das Referenzdesign von Nvidia?
Wahrscheinlich.
Also, wenn man die am Anfang
nur ordentlich bei Nvidia direkt
vorbestellen kann, dann das. Also ich hab jetzt die
letzten 3 oder 4 Grafikkarten
nur im Nvidia Referenzdesign
gehabt, da hatte ich überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit. Die sind
mittlerweile auch wirklich in Ordnung.
Es sei denn, ähm, man will
äh, ne
Wasserkühlung haben.
Fragt doch Nvidia. Ja gut, dazu müsste ich
erst, ich hab ja die letzten 3 oder 4
4 Karten, glaub ich, von Nvidia gekriegt.
Aber dafür mach ich, ich mach ja grad nix.
Und wenn ich nix mach, lohnt sich das für Nvidia
auch nicht. Da bin ich mir auch zu doof, da zu fragen.
So nach dem Motto, hallo, könnt ihr, äh,
krieg ich ne, krieg ich ne 2500
Euro Grafikkarte umsonst? Ich, äh,
halt die dann auch mal kurz ins Bild
auf nem Stream, wo 200 Leute zu gucken.
Ich glaub, das interessiert die nicht so sehr.
Ähm, auf Youtube war das interessanter,
aber da müsste ich halt mal was machen, dass es
dann sich wieder lohnt, ja.
Beste Grafikkarte, Matrox Millennium
G550. Ja,
Moment, das gibt es noch?
Die gab's vor 20 Jahren mal.
Ah gut, ähm,
ach, aber nee, nee, nee, nee.
Also ich muss sagen,
ich, also,
ich bin geneigt, hier, warte mal,
was, warte mal, wann war denn das?
Moment, Moment, wann ist das
24. haben die gesagt?
Donnerstag!
So ein Kacktag! Da kann
ich doch nicht mal abends um 24, da muss ich
morgens arbeiten gehen.
Was meinen die eigentlich mit verfügbar?
Meinen die denn, man kann die hier über, äh,
hat das schon mal jemand gemacht? Also heißt
das, wenn die verfügbar sind, dass dann hier ein Kaufen-Knopf
kommt? Nee, einfach
von der Arbeit aus bringt ja nix.
Ich muss ja nachts, wenn die das hier
freischalten um 24 Uhr oder so,
muss ich dann hier draufklicken, sonst krieg ich keine.
Okay, man kann den Kram direkt,
ah, Nvidia, hier.
Keine transparenten Bilder.
WeirdChamp.
So geht's ja net.
Und ich hab die Seite sogar,
also das ist kein Dark Reader,
die Seite sieht standardmäßig so hässlich aus.
WeirdChamp
Nvidia.
Ich weiß, dass das keine, äh, keine
3000er sind. Ich wollt gucken, wie das
normalerweise mit dem Einkaufen hier aussieht.
Moin, Kengin.
So, ähm, tja,
den brauch ich net. Also, dann
wär ich, hat das jemand schon mal gemacht?
Wie viel Uhr schalten die den Kram frei?
Wann schalten die das frei?
24.9.300
Facebook.
Zulull. Was wollen wir denn mit Facebook?
Currys.co
What?
Was zum Teufel ist Currys PC World?
Außerdem ist das UK.
Also,
das wird folgendermaßen laufen. Ich sag,
ich sag euch jetzt mal, wie es ist.
Keiner,
der, keiner,
der, der Leute, der, der nicht Ultra-Click
hat, wird am 24.9. eine Grafikhalle
bestellen können. So.
Danach denken die Leute, ah,
okay, gehste Guides halt gucken,
Guides halt gucken, auch alles ausverkauft.
So. Dann kommen die
ersten Läden, so irgendwie eins,
zwei Wochen später auf die Idee, die welche haben,
verkaufen die für das Doppelte.
Und es werden sich Leute kaufen. Für
2500 Euro.
So. Ähm,
dann ist das wieder weg, weil das alle gekauft
haben. Und irgendwann
dann, Ende des Jahres, kannst du,
wobei, dann kommt Weihnachten, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht auch nicht Ende des Jahres. Vielleicht,
vielleicht auch erst nächstes Jahr, wenn
ihr das dann ordentlich kaufen kannst. Obwohl es, obwohl es
24.9. rauskommt.
Deswegen fragt dann, ich kenn auch nicht mal, ich kenn
niemanden mehr bei Nvidia. Die sind alle nicht
mal bei Nvidia.
Ich würd's gar nicht mehr fragen, so.
Keine Ahnung. Ähm,
muss auch nicht sein.
Nee, nee, ich kauf mir das Ding, dann hab ich da auch keinerlei Verpflichtung.
Oder sonst was.
Schreib ein Programm, das Auto
beimacht. Das ist eine
exzellente Idee. Das Problem ist
nur, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie die Seite
aussehen wird. Ich kann das nicht skripten oder
automatisieren, weil ich nicht weiß, wie die Seite aussehen
wird. Weil man sie kaufen kann.
Naja.
Wurscht.
Guck mal. Also wir gucken, wir gucken
24.9. muss ich mal aufschreiben.
Hatten wir schon.
24.9. Nvidia.
So. Event ist das.
Ähm.
Jetzt fehlt
ja echt nur noch eine neue Ryzen
CPU. Gibt's da schon irgendwelche
Leaks?
Leak?
So. Nee.
Ah, Moment, es ist 4950
X. Leak.
New Leak.
Ah ja, das klingt natürlich
sehr vertrauenserweckend.
Ja, das sind ja ganz tolle, ganz tolle Sachen.
Das ist besser. Moment.
Ich kann auch nicht richtig
schreiben, ne?
Leak has appeared.
Das haben wir uns doch schon mal angeguckt vom 6. August.
Das ist doch schon einen Monat alt. Das interessiert doch keinen mehr.
Aber was Neues. Neues hier.
Tools. Anytime. Eine Woche
alt. So. Hier.
Leak. Leak. Also.
Might be launching in Oktober. Ja, excellent.
Auf geht's.
September, Oktober nächsten Monat.
Excellent. Das, das wär gut.
Kein Interesse an
einer 3080 TI.
Es gibt keine 3080 TI.
Webarchive
vom 2000er Release.
Das ist ne gute Idee.
Können wir mal gucken, wie die Seite
zum 2000er Release aussah.
Big Brain
Idee Chat.
Wann war der 2000er?
Haben die nicht gesagt, es wird keine
3080 TI geben?
Gut, die sagen viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Als ob Nvidia gleich
eine Seite macht. Warum nicht?
20. September
18.
Oh, guck mal, davor gab's die nicht.
Ja.
Excellent. Snapshot.
Moment. Moment. September?
November?
Wann? Moment.
Ach, September.
Ja, da gibt's die Seite nicht.
Wie sahen die hier aus?
Webarchive.
Ah.
Guck mal, die Seite ist ja ziemlich
gut.
Also, Leute, guckt mal.
Jeder, der sagt, als ob Nvidia
die gleiche Seite macht.
Guckt euch mal die Seite an.
Sieht die anders aus?
Die sieht zwei Jahre später noch genauso aus.
Max 2 pro Kunde, derzeit nicht verfügbar.
Vielleicht nicht.
Das ist tatsächlich ne gute Idee.
Das ist ne gute Idee.
Wir gucken mal, wie die englische Seite heißt.
Vielleicht ist es einfach so.
GeForce Buy, ohne irgendwas.
E-N-U-S vielleicht?
Was?
E-N-U-S?
Gibt's nicht.
Nope.
Denied.
Mein Browser ist eigentlich auf Englisch.
Guck mal, ich hab fast alles auf Englisch.
Home, Trending, Subscriptions.
Eigentlich, das ist
Geo-IP-mäßig.
Naja. Hätte ich jetzt NordVPN?
Ja. Aber wunderbar.
Die Seite sieht genauso aus im Endeffekt.
Ich guck mal.
24.9. nachts.
Max, was macht der Friseur in Kapoum?
Leben die noch?
Ja, mit dem Kapoum war ich gestern erst
gestern seit 6 Monaten das erste Mal wieder in Frankfurt.
Und als ich Zug gefahren bin,
gab's gleich Stress,
weil ein Fahrradfahrer
seine Maske, also der hat
keine Maske gehabt.
Und da haben sie gleich Stress gemacht, alle.
Da ist die richtige
PEGA-Action am Start gewesen.
Video aufgenommen? Ja.
Ne. Naja.
Hm. Ja und?
Steht da jetzt irgendein Datum dabei?
Oktober-Launch ist almost certain.
Na dann.
Wie war denn das bei der letzten
AMD
Ryzen-Generation?
Der 3950X kam
ein bisschen später.
Der 3950X kam ein bisschen später, ne?
Release Date.
Wann kam der denn raus?
Date?
Hier.
Ja, ok.
Das auf dem Papier, auf dem Papier.
Praktisch gesehen kam der da glaube ich nicht raus.
Neue Tiefstpreise.
Ok, kostet immer noch 1000 Euro.
In dem Dreh. Ne, ne, ne. Weniger, weniger.
Äh, ich glaube 600 oder so.
Was kosten 3000 aktuell?
600, ja so.
Also da muss ich schon sehr viel Glück haben,
dass ich mir am Ende des Jahres einen neuen Rechner bauen kann.
Ich muss irgendwie eine Grafikkarte
bekommen und irgendwie
hoffen, dass AMD,
jetzt, ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll.
Also,
die, die, äh,
rationalere Variante wäre,
also die, ne,
die Köpfchen-Variante wäre eigentlich
zu warten,
bis ein 3490,
äh,
4959X rauskommt.
Weil das, bis man den ordentlich
bekommt,
ist es eh nächstes Jahr.
So, und dann kaufe ich mir nächstes Jahr
im Februar ganz,
in Ruhe einen neuen Rechner.
Bis dahin gibt es die CPUs dann auch
lieferbar, die Grafikkarten lieferbar
und bis dahin gibt es auch
halbwegs sinnvolle,
äh, 4 Terabyte NVMe
SSDs, weil aktuell
ist das ja alles nicht so,
nicht so sinnvoll, ja.
Ich, ich will, äh, Samsung, hier.
Das lohnt sich nicht.
So, weil das hier, das geht ja eigentlich
hier. Kann man sich doch nicht mal beschweren
hier, für den.
Aber ich glaube, hier hatten wir,
hier hatten wir schon mal den Test gelesen
und das Problem war,
das Problem war, dass die viel zu heiß
werden, ne. Hatten wir nicht schon mal einen Test
gelesen? Ist 2x
2 Terabyte vielleicht günstiger,
vielleicht?
Stimmt.
Bisschen. Ja, bisschen
billiger. 100 Euro oder so.
90 Euro billiger.
Aber dann könnt, dann, ich brauche ja gar keine
4 Terabyte wirklich, ne. Also,
äh,
ich habe, aktuell habe
ich eine 2 Terabyte SSD
und eine 500,
also eine, eine NVMe
2 Terabyte SSD und eine NVMe
512G SSD
und eine 6 Terabyte
Festplatte. Das reicht ja auch voll und ganz,
das reicht ja auch echt dicke, dicke aus.
Und ich dachte mir halt,
wenn ich mal einen neuen Rechner kaufe, dann gehe ich mal wieder so voll
in, in die Vollen und,
äh, mache eine 4 Terabyte SSD rein.
Eine 3900, äh,
RTX und
einen 4950, äh,
XRyzen.
So, da, der ganze Rechner kostet dann wahrscheinlich 4000 Euro,
aber, haben.
Ja.
Ja, naja.
Wurscht. Gucken wir mal. Was können wir uns
für Videos angucken? Äh, hast du
im Stream schon mal einen VPN-Server mit Zugriff
auf so lokale Netzwerke?
Äh, wir haben mal WireGuard gemacht,
im Stream.
Wir haben mal, wir haben mal WireGuard gemacht.
Ist aber ewig her.
Naja.
Irgendwas, irgendwelche Sachen im Chat übersehen,
sag mal, ja.
Google-Vorschläge teilweise.
Vor allem seitdem die ganzen China-Shops
da auch am Start sind in der Google-Shop-Suche.
Ich warte ja aktuell
noch auf eine Lieferung von Banggood.
Ich habe mir hier ein paar
bestellt, weil die irgendwie so eine Aktionswoche hatten.
Also die, das sind diese
Boards, die wir auch mal zusammen
zusammen im Stream uns angeguckt,
also zusammen gebastelt haben.
Ich habe nämlich gerade eine Aktion am Start gehabt.
Ähm,
eins für die Hälfte
quasi. Und da habe ich
drei Stück bestellt aus China.
Ich überlege, kostet halt nur
3,29 Euro Versand.
Ich glaube, ich habe sogar EU-Priority-Line
gemacht.
So, dann bin ich mal gespannt,
wann die wirklich ankommen.
Die Sendeverfolgung ist
ein bisschen Fail, was Banggood angeht.
Da steht dann nur so Sachen wie
Handled to Aircraft Carrier.
Aber ich
wusste gar nicht, dass ein Flugzeugträger
meine Pakete ausfährt.
Was hältst du
von der Sache? Wirklich gutes Video.
Okay, zeig mal.
100 Betriebssysteme von einem
USB-Stick booten.
Können wir uns mal angucken, wenn du willst.
Lahmes Netz. Deutschland hinkt beim
Ausbau des Glasfasernetzes
hinterher. Na, da muss ich mir keinen Beitrag
vom ZDF angucken. Das ist
so, ja. Ja, ich meine,
allein schon der Titel, ja,
das ist so.
Und wisst ihr, eine Sache,
wo ich mich heute immer noch
frage, warum
das nicht mehr Leute
einsehen, was diese Sache hier angeht, ist,
könnt ihr euch noch an die,
wann waren das,
UMTS-Versteigerung,
wann waren die UMTS-Zeugversteigerung?
Okay, das ist,
das war 2000. Da werden sich wahrscheinlich
nicht viele von euch dran erinnern, ja.
Ähm,
aber so im Jahr 2000 rum wurden
UMTS-Lizenzen, also das 3G ist das,
glaube ich, ne, wurden UMTS-Lizenzen
versteigert.
Für unglaublich viel Geld.
Und
damals war das so,
dass
man gesagt hat, ich kann mich da noch dran erinnern,
das Land, also,
ne, das Land, der Staat, Deutschland halt,
da hat damals gesagt,
wir versteigern die Lizenzen an Mobilfunkanbieter
zum Höchstbieten,
drei, drei, ich glaube, drei Anbieter haben die Lizenzen
bekommen. Letztendlich war es die Telekom,
ähm,
das, das, was dann irgendwann mal E-Plus wurde,
und, und das, was jetzt Vodafone ist,
frag mich nicht, wie der Kram damals, damals hieß.
So, und
alle anderen Anbieter
wurden quasi rausgedrängt,
also man hat sich komplett die Chance drauf
verbaut, dass es vielleicht mal mehr als
zwei, drei große Anbieter gibt.
Ähm,
und
das Problem dabei war nur,
dass die Anbieter
Milliarden bezahlt haben für UMTS-Lizenzen.
Dementsprechend,
was macht ein Anbieter, der Milliarden
für UMTS-Lizenzen bezahlt hat?
Der wird erstmal nur dort
ausbauen, wo es besonders lukrativ ist.
Also, du baust vielleicht in der Stadt
UMTS aus, aber du baust nicht auf dem Land UMTS
aus. Deswegen haben wir heute noch so viele
Mobilfunklücken. Dass wir heute noch so viele
Mobilfunklücken haben, liegt meiner Ansicht nach
zum größten Teil an der UMTS-Versteigerung.
Hätten die, hätten das, meine Ansicht
nach, so retrospektivisch,
ja,
exzellent, big brain-Wort,
ähm, hätte man das anders machen sollen, man hätte,
man hätte das den Anbietern geben sollen,
ich weiß nicht, ob man es ihnen
hätte umsonst geben sollen, was weiß
ich, aber mal angenommen, man hätte es den Anbietern
umsonst gegeben, aber nur
dem Anbieter, oder den Anbietern,
die sich verpflichten,
und wir reden jetzt hier nicht von so
so diese, so diese, diese
lari, wischi waschi
Verpflichtungen, so nach dem Motto, bis 2000
77, musst du sonst was machen, ne,
nur den Anbietern geben, die sich
verpflichten, ordentlich
auszubauen, kontrolliert,
ordentlich, jedes Jahr gucken, dass die
das einhalten, wenn die das nicht einhalten,
auch keine Strafe bezahlen, sondern
mit Androhung einfach Lizenzen entziehen,
bam, weil dann hätten die keine Chance
gehabt, das nicht auszubauen, ja.
Ähm,
so, und,
dann hätten wir deutlich bessere, was, zumindest was Mobilfunk
angeht, deutlich bessere, ähm,
Let's Up, der
weil die Anbieter, denen hätte, wäre gar keine
andere Wahl geblieben, erstens hätten die Milliarden
gespart, an UMTS Lizenzen,
äh, und zweitens, hätten die
ausbauen müssen, an die Schweiz
kriegt das auch besser hin, es kriegt das,
es kriegt das, die meisten Länder
kriegen das besser hin, die meisten, sagen wir mal,
nicht unbedingt dritte Weltländer, kriegen
das besser hin, und sogar manche dritte
Weltländer kriegen das besser hin, äh.
Ja, ähm,
das war, das war
eine bescheuerte Idee, und ich weiß noch,
damals, hatten das alle geil,
damals alle hier auch so, aus
meinem Bekanntenkreis, haben damals
gesagt, wie alt war ich denn da, 2000, da war
ich 16, ja, ähm, die haben alle
so gesagt, ah, ist doch geil, also die Älteren, ja,
die, so die, das war noch die richtige,
also wer 2000 so den Älteren
gezählt hat, das war so die richtige
Hardcore-Boomer-Generation,
ja, die haben alle gesagt, ja, ist doch geil,
dann gibt es endlich richtig
Geld, damit kann man Schulden ausbauen, ja nur, dass
du vom, vom Schuldenabbau kein,
kein ordentliches UMTS-Netz kriegst.
Das war Hardcore-Boomer.
Sag mal, geht bei euch das Boomer-Emote? Wir haben doch ein
Boomer-Emote irgendwo.
Wenn das meine Tastatur
nicht umgestellt hätte.
Ja.
Haben wir doch.
Ja, und das ist
meine Ansicht nach eines der
großen, äh, Fails
gewesen, warum wir so schlechte, oder warum wir
so viele, äh,
Lücken haben, was Mobilfunk
angeht. Ich mein, ich hab's gestern wieder gesehen,
ich bin gestern gefahren von Hanau nach,
äh, Frankfurt Süd,
und auf,
zu der Höhe von Maintal
hast du immer Aussetzer,
immer. Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
im März, ähm,
im März ging diese ganze Corona-Homeoffice-
Geschichte los. Und da war ich gerade auf dem
Heimweg, da hat mein Chef eine Einladung
geschickt, so nach dem Motto, äh,
wichtige Informationen, Krisenstab,
Besprechungen, so. Und da stand ich Frankfurt
Süd am Bahnhof,
hab mir mein Headset ins Ohr gemacht,
und hab an der Teams-Konferenz damals
teilgenommen, wo es drum ging, dass wir
ab jetzt alle erstmal Homeoffice machen müssen,
weil Corona. Und ich bin im Zug
heimgefahren, und es ist, oh ne
Scheiße, es ist alle zwei Minuten abgeschissen.
Das ist doch lächerlich.
Und ich hab sogar,
äh, ich hab's mir nicht, das war sogar
nur Audio, nur Audio.
Ja.
Max benutzt Teams, ja, was soll ich
dann machen, wenn wir auf der Arbeit Teams verwenden? Das ist ja
nicht so, dass ich sagen kann, ja, ähm,
also, wenn ihr mit mir reden wollt, dann müsst ihr Discord
verwenden. Ich glaube, das funktioniert
nicht so ganz. Was ist das denn?
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an,
wo wir grad beim Thema Grafikkarten sind.
Weiß nicht, warum
ich das aufgemacht hab.
In der Schweiz, ja, 5G
ist in der Schweiz ziemlich weit vorne.
Ja. Was aber witzig ist,
es gibt in der, es gibt in der Schweiz,
ähm, dadurch, dass
die so viel 5G-Ausbau haben, auch, äh,
sehr viele 5G-Gegner,
die dann erzählen,
dass, ähm, Gehirnschäden
entstehen und solche Dinger.
Okay,
wahrscheinlich ist das schlecht. Aber, also,
so, ich hab noch keinen Resitas
gesehen, der wirklich schlecht war.
Gucken, okay, das können wir uns danach angucken.
ZFGS, wir gucken uns jetzt ne Runde,
äh, ja, zwei Stück oder so an.
Moment, ich weiß, dass man,
ich glaub, nen Ticken lauter kann ich machen.
Keck W.
Okay.
Ja, gut.
Ich verstehe, es ist scheiße
für die Leute, die sich ne 2.000...
Wir gucken erst mal fertig.
Aber da muss ich was zu sagen nachher.
Ich verstehe, es ist scheiße für die Leute,
die sich ne 2.000...
Wir gucken erst mal fertig.
Aber da muss ich was zu sagen nachher.
Ja, gut.
Okay, okay.
erstmal fertig, aber da muss ich was zu sagen nachher.
Et tu?
Das ist ja Raytracing-Sau,
wo die sie durchs Dorf getrieben haben.
Naja, also,
Moment.
Also,
so ganz stimmt das nicht,
muss ich sagen. Also, man sollte
sich nicht beschweren,
wirklich, wenn man
vor zwei Jahren sich eine High-End-Grafikkarte
gekauft hat und es jetzt
zwei Jahre später
was für die Hälfte des Preises gibt,
was schneller ist.
Ganz ehrlich, zwei Jahre
ist saumäßig lang. Ich weiß,
dass das mittlerweile nicht mehr so ist.
Ich mein, guck mal, ich hab mich
den letzten Stream doch schon mal drüber aufgeregt.
Ich hab mir vor drei Jahren, ziemlich genau
drei Jahren,
einen neuen Rechner gekauft.
Hier, da, sorry. Oktober,
also das ist ziemlich genau fast
drei Jahre her. So, und der Rechner,
den ich mir
gekauft habe, vor drei
Jahren,
mit
8700K, ein bisschen über
1080Ti, gehört immer noch
heute, drei Jahre, das muss man sich mal
vorstellen, das gab es
noch vor nicht allzu langer Zeit, gab's
das nie. Drei Jahre später immer noch
zu den Top 5% der Systeme.
So, und
das ist absolut der Luxus
aktuell, dass man seine Hardware so lang
verwenden kann. Wenn man sich, wenn man mal
zurückguckt, 2000, 2005, auch noch ein bisschen
danach, bis 2010 herum
vielleicht,
also gerade aber 2000, 2000, bis
2005 herum,
da war ein Rechner nach zwei Jahren, selbst wenn
das ein richtig teurer, guter Rechner war, absoluter
Shit. Den konntest, du konntest
damit quasi die Sachen
auf low, wenn du Glück hattest,
vielleicht starten.
So, und nach drei Jahren war
das Ding absolut schrottreif, komplett.
Also es ist absoluter Luxus,
dass man so einen Rechner heute drei Jahre verwenden
kann und er immer noch zu den besten Systemen gehört.
Also Luxus für, für Leute, die
quasi nicht, sich nicht laufen, neue
Hardware kaufen wollen. Ich find's doof,
ich fänd's besser, wenn die Entwicklung schneller gehen würde,
und, dass man sich
jetzt nach zwei Monaten, nach zwei Jahren aufregen
kann, dass es jetzt eine Grafikkarte
gibt, für die Hälfte des Preises, die
schneller ist, ja,
gut, ne?
Und, ja, es gibt
Leute, die haben sich das vor einem Monat
gekauft, weil sie nicht wussten, dass was
Neues rauskommt, aber ganz,
ganz im Ernst,
das ist ja nicht das erste Mal so. Also wenn man die Sache
ein bisschen verfolgt hat, dann weiß
man ungefähr, in welchem Abstand was rauskommt.
Ähm,
und ich würde, ich würde nie den
vollen Preis bezahlen, zwei Jahre nachdem
eine Generation rausgekommen ist, auch wenn die noch nicht
das Neue angekündigt haben, das ist so bescheuert.
Also was die, was die, was die
früher ganz gerne gemacht haben, und ich weiß nicht,
wie es heute ist, die haben meistens noch die
alten, die alten Grafikkarten dann recht günstig
verkauft, wenn eine neue Generation rausgekommen ist.
Ich hab mir damals ne,
boah, was war denn das, GTX, GTO
oder sowas, ähm,
äh,
das ist schon ewig her,
ja, sowas. Ich hab mir damals,
übrigens, witzigerweise,
waren wir vor 15 Jahren schon mal
ungefähr bei der, ähm,
bei größeren
Zahlen, bei größeren Zahlen als jetzt.
Ja, da waren wir bei 7.900.
Ähm, so vor 15 Jahren.
Und ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, ich hab
damals ne, ne
7.900 GTO gekauft,
weil die neue Generation
rausgekommen ist und das Ding quasi die Hälfte
gekostet hat von der GTX. Damals,
damals haben wir auch so von, von, von 500
Euro oder so geredet. Alten die
Konsolen den Fortschritt nicht krass zurück?
Die Konsolen halten, also wenn
überhaupt halten die Konsolen den Fortschritt
so weit zurück, dass, ähm,
die Spieleentwickler gucken, dass der Kram
halt gut auf der Konsole laufen muss und dann
vielleicht nicht noch Extraspirenzien
für den PC einbauen, aber ansonsten
würde ich sagen, hält sich das in Grenzen? Das wirkt
so, das wirkt so, weil, weil
sich allgemein Hardwareleistungstechnisch
die letzten 10 Jahre nicht mehr allzu viel tut.
Das würde ich nicht unbedingt auf die Konsolen schieben.
Weil auch CPU-Leistung
an sich, wenn du mal so durch, du,
drumherum guckst, was jetzt überhaupt nichts mit Konsolen zu tun hat,
das, das ist alles
deutlich langsamer, als das früher war.
Was, was
Konsolen machen, sind immer, ähm,
so API-Geschichten,
so, da, X10, 11,
12, äh, was auch immer,
irgendwie so ein bisschen, bisschen neuen,
neuen Spirenzien, ja, das ist
so von Konsolengeneration zu Konsolengeneration.
Aber so gen, so allgemein
die Hardwareentwicklung würde ich nicht sagen. Auf der anderen
Seite ist es sogar eher so, dass die fette
Kohle auf der Konsole verdient wird.
Immer noch.
Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel.
Und
vieles wäre ohne Konsolen so gar nicht drin.
Nein.
Ne. Glaube ich nicht, dass
das, dass da die Konsolen dran schuld sind.
Es ist einfach die letzten Jahre alles
langsamer geworden an Hardwareentwicklung.
So, was sollen wir, den sollten wir uns jetzt auch noch
angucken, okay.
Geck weh.
Können die alle mal die gleiche Lautstärke machen,
dass man nicht immer rumstellen muss?
Ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt. Die 1080 TI war eigentlich zu schnell.
Deswegen hab ich mir auch, also was heißt eigentlich zu
schnell? Die war zu schnell, dass sich die 2000, das heißt
jetzt Upgrade lohnt auf eine 2080. Und, ähm, deswegen hab, ich
hab auch nicht Upgrade, hab ich den Sinn überhaupt nicht drin
gesehen.
Pero, Ricitá, que? Ve por la paellera. Venga, que las dos de la tarde, ya están aquí.
Mira el bañador. La chancla. Todo despeinado, porque no me dio tiempo
nada ponerme la chancla y el bañador. Voy a la playa, ya subió la marea.
.
Im Prinzip ist genau der gleiche Inhalt wie das andere.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich finde, da muss man sich zwei Jahre später nicht beschweren.
.
1.800 oder
900 Euro oder 1.000 oder was auch immer.
Aber
also,
wenn man irgendwie
sich ein bisschen die letzten Jahre das Ganze
verfolgt hat, ist man blöde,
wenn man zwei Jahre später für einen
absoluten Vollpreis sich eine alte
Generation kauft.
Da ist man einfach bescheuert.
Ja, das Verge-PC-Bild-Video
war das Beste.
Ne, das ist
beknackt.
Es ist doch sogar gut,
ich weiß gar nicht, worüber sie sich aufregen,
es ist doch sogar gut,
wenn du jetzt eine Grafikkarte kriegst
für die
Hälfte.
Also, finde ich, das ist echt nicht schlimm.
Oh, das
darf natürlich auch nicht fehlen,
20 Rico. Das Problem ist, dass ich
die Videos auf Deutsch halt nicht lustig finde, weil ich sie verstehe.
Risitas finden wahrscheinlich Leute,
die Spanisch verstehen, auch nicht lustig.
Wann werden neue AMD-CPUs
eigentlich vorgestellt? Ja, das frage ich mich auch.
Genau das frage ich mich auch.
Da warte ich ja noch drauf.
Also, ich hab jetzt
die Auswahl,
was Sinnvolles zu machen,
nämlich einfach
zu warten, bis neue AMD-CPUs
und die
verfügbar sind, sodass man sie sich
kaufen kann, ohne irgendwie nachts
irgendwelche Vorbesteller-Sachen zu machen.
Oder aber, ich mach was Bescheuertes,
ich kaufe mir jetzt schon
eine 3090
am 24.09.
Nachts setze ich mich da hin und spam den
jetzt-vorbestellen-Button.
Und
dann baue ich die
in meinen aktuellen Rechner ein und warte
halt, bis AMD rauskommt.
Also,
das eine wäre sinnvoll
und das andere wäre, ich will
jetzt was Neues und Geld ausgeben. Tja, ich weiß
auch nicht so genau. Warum
nicht ZF-Grips? Die wollen ja gar nicht so viel.
Die wollen den Kram verkaufen.
Also, ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher. Mal gucken, mal gucken.
Also, wenn AMD wirklich
das Ganze vorstellt jetzt im Oktober
und dann muss ja auch noch
eine 4950X rauskommen,
dass sich das lohnt.
Oder so, mal gucken.
Dann, dann, ja,
mal gucken. Ich weiß es echt nicht.
Informatikerlöhne
in der Schweiz, sag mal was dazu.
Können wir machen. Wobei, Schweizer
Sachen kann man nicht so gut mit Deutschen machen.
Äh,
mit Eltern so vergleichen.
Kostet doch alles viel mehr.
Spezialisierte IT verdienen
im Schnitt 150
Das ist ordentlich. Das ist
exzellent.
Dafür kostet der Schweizer auch alles mehr.
Das ist, das ist, äh,
dann würde ich einfach,
am besten wäre es ja, wenn man in der
Schweiz arbeitet und das Geld kriegt und in
Deutschland wohnt.
Ja, ok, was?
Click to flip.
Das ist ordentlich.
Das ist, das ist mehr als
die meisten hier so verdienen.
Mediamatik.
Was ist denn ein Mediamatiker?
Mediamatiker.
ICT.
Was ist ein ICT Operator?
ICT Supporter.
Die Schweizer haben komische Wörter.
Was ist das?
Okay, okay, was würde ich in der Schweiz
verdienen?
Guck mal hier. Easy Money.
Sourcing Manager. Die haben wir gerade so
geile. Program Manager.
So viel Wauze hat's hochgegangen.
Ja.
Ja, ist doch gut.
Also ich würde, ich würde das, wenn ich, wenn ich könnte, würde ich das auch so machen.
In der Schweiz Geld, also wenn ich in der
Schweiz wohne, würde ich in der Schweiz arbeiten und in Deutschland
einkaufen. Das ist doch optimal und besseres
Geld kannst du doch nicht machen.
Ist doch top.
Exzellent.
So, also was
Chat, das hier soll ich mir angucken.
Das ist aber wieder so ein Thema, wo ich mich wahrscheinlich jetzt drüber
aufregen würde, ja.
Wie Polen bei uns.
Stimmt, der
Master Grabber, also der
Kollege da vom
aus Dresden, der fährt
auch immer, das ist aber so eh der
übelste Sparfuchs.
Der fährt auch immer nach Polen in den
Supermarkt und sowas und kauft da da
irgendwie Wasserflaschen und Gedöns.
Okay, bitte das ZD, alles klar.
Okay, wir gucken uns das jetzt an. Aber wahrscheinlich ist es ein Thema, wo ich
erstmal hier eine Runde,
wo haben wir das passende, haben wir da, haben wir überhaupt irgendwie
so einen Swift Rage
Emote? Irgendwie sowas?
Haben wir, haben wir
einen Aufrege Emote?
Leute, müssen wir mal kurz gucken.
Habe ich irgendeinen Emote, wo man, wo sich jemand aufregt?
Habe ich gar nicht, oder?
Naja, schauen wir mal.
Pipo Rage.
Gucken wir kein USB Video.
Was?
Achso, wegen Aufregen.
Ne, das hatten wir das letzte Mal ja erst.
Vordorf, eine 3000
Einwohner Gemeinde in Niedersachsen.
Rund 15 Kilometer von Braunschweig
entfernt. In diesem Haus
lebt Familie Biebel.
Laut genug?
Familie Biebel?
Ist hier wirklich Familie Biebel?
Braunschweig entfernt.
In diesem Haus lebt Familie Biebel.
Bless RNG.
Mädels, ich habe eine super Idee.
Mensch, ärgere dich nicht
in 2020.
Cringe.
Katja Biebel und ihre Töchter Stella und Gina
verbringen im Nachmittag...
Nein, komm, das ist ZDF, da kannst du nicht erwarten,
dass man mehr als 720p at 50 kriegt.
... mit Brettspielen.
Bei Biebels ist die Freizeitgestaltung
zwangsläufig analog.
Ihre Internetverbindung ist zu langsam
für Online-Games, Netflix und Co.
Okay, also was haben die für eine
Internetverbindung, dass sie zu langsam
für Internet-Spiele ist?
Ich meine ernsthaft, Spiele brauchen
so gut wie nichts an Bandbreite.
Außer beim Download.
Und man spielt Warzone, dann muss man
200 GB runterladen.
Aber während dem Spielen selbst,
also Spiele brauchen keine Bandbreite.
Katja Biebel arbeitet
für einen großen Automobil.
Die heißen ernsthaft Biebel, Alter.
Viele ihrer Kollegen
sitzen wegen Corona...
Ping wird nicht bequatscht.
Was soll man da zu tun?
Es sei denn, du hast Satellit oder sowas.
... die 52-Jährige aber muss
jeden Tag ins Büro.
Exzellent, Tastatur.
Wir bekommen maximal 2 MBit.
Reicht doch!
Also, Moment, für Spielen 2 MBit.
Vollkommen okay.
Für alles andere, für den Arsch.
Aber zum Spielen reichen 2 MBit.
Absolut ohne Probleme.
... um Homeoffice zu machen.
Und Remote Desktop 2 MBit mag auch
hinhauen, aber es ist nicht schön.
Im Internet-Geschwindigkeit
kann keine Rede sein.
Die Verbindung ist so langsam,
dass Videos nur ruckeln.
Das heute-Journal mit Marietta Slomka
dauert mit Unterbrechungen fast 3 Stunden.
Der Grund, Daten kommen hier über
eine alte Kupferleitung der Telekom ins Haus.
Katja Biebel testet die Übertragungsrate.
Heute gerade mal
1,1 MBit pro Sekunde.
Das lahme Netz
auch ein Problem für ihre Töchter.
Die 17-jährige Stella
und 14-jährige Gina brauchen das Internet
zum Lernen. Als ihre Schulen
wegen Corona online unterrichtet haben,
waren sie aufgeschmissen.
Das kriegen sie in Deutschland nicht gescheit gebacken
mit Online-Unterricht.
Meistens, wenn ich halt
eine richtig große Datei hab zum
runterladen, muss ich dann auch irgendwo anders hinfahren.
Er hat hier die ultra-tiefe Stimme, oder?
... zu meinem Onkel und meiner Tante
und das ist halt auch normal, da muss man
den Fahrtweg einfach mit einberichten.
Stella und Gina fühlen sich digital
abgehängt und dadurch benachteiligt.
Es ist so unfair,
dass die
drei Häuser weiter im Neubaugebiet
haben Glasfaser
und wir sind hier und wissen nicht,
was wir machen sollen.
Ihr Problem? Starlink.
Wobei das mit Starlink, ne, also
der große Heilsbringer
wird das nicht, so wie jetzt manche da
vielleicht hoffen. Kann ich euch jetzt schon
sagen.
Das wird, äh, wahrscheinlich wird
sogar mehr Probleme machen, als dass es
Leuten in abgelegenen Regionen großartig
was bringt.
Familie Bibel wohnt auf der falschen Straßenseite.
200 Meter entfernt ist
ein Neubaugebiet. Hier gibt es
Glasfaser mit lichtschnellem Internet.
Lichtschnelles Internet.
... in Sichtweite und doch
unerreichbar für Bibels und ihre Nachbarn.
Und genau
dagegen wehren sich die Einwohner
verschiedener Ortsteile. Ihre Bürgerinitiative
fordert schnelles Internet
für alle. Warum muss es
dazu überhaupt ne fucking Bürgerinitiative
geben? Die müssen mal mit ihrem Scheiß
beikommen.
Dieses Thema geht mir so auf den Sack.
Egal, weiter.
... kritisieren, die Gemeinde ist ein
digitales Flickwerk. Es gibt zig
verschiedene Anbieter und zig verschiedene Technologien,
die jeweils im Dorf aufgeteilt sind.
Ähm, Aikos hat zum Beispiel ein Neubaugebiet,
da gibt's Glasfaser bis zum Haus, während
der alte Ortskern entweder Richtfunk nutzen
muss oder Kupfer. Pichtfunk. Und das ist
in meinen Augen eine Zweiklassendigitalisierung.
Richtfunk ist richtig pepega.
Wie Zweiklassendigitalisierung konkret aussieht,
zeigen sie uns in dieser Straße.
...
Also dieser Straße liegt zum einen das Kupferkabel
noch von der Telekom, plus jetzt
komplett neu das Glasfaserkabel,
was dann hier reinschwenkt ins Neubaugebiet.
Aber dann ist doch alles gut, wenn Sie sagen... Einfach
sein Haus umsetzen, hä?
... bereits das Glasfaserkabel, ja dann herzlichen
Glückwunsch, dann sind Sie ja schon ganz weit vorne.
Hier sind wir aber im Herzen der Zweiklassendigitalisierung.
Die Leute, die hier an der Straße
wohnen, die dürfen nicht angeschlossen werden. Nur dieses
Neubaugebiet mit den 30 Häusern hat Glasfaser
bis zum Haus. Das ist halt richtig fail wieder.
... wörtlich in die Röhre gucken.
Wir kommen in Absurdistan.
Bei Neubauten sind Glasfaseranschlüsse
bis zum Haus seit 2016 vorgeschrieben.
An bestehenden Gebäuden
darf das schnelle Netz aber vorbeigelegt
werden. Deshalb schließt die
Telekom auch hier nur das Neubaugebiet
an. Die sind gewappnet
für die Zukunft. Die Alteikoster
und die Redner und die Vordorfer, die sind es nicht.
Und deshalb kämpfen wir für Glasfaser bis
in die Häuser. Das ist so unglaublich
beknackt. ... Bürgerinnen und Bürger
unserer Gemeinde.
Wir fragen die Deutsche Telekom
AG, warum sie nur diese Häuser
an das Glasfasernetz anschließt.
Ein Interview bekommen wir nicht.
Schriftlich teilt das Unternehmen mit,
in den älteren Ortsteilen
seien bereits andere Internetanbieter
aktiv. Wörtlich heißt es,
einen eigenen Netzausbau in diesem
Bereich plant die Deutsche Telekom
nicht. Dieser wäre unwirtschaftlich.
Das ist
einer meiner Hauptkritikpunkte, sei es
jetzt generell Infrastrukturausbau.
Es sollte nicht
drum gehen, auch bei
medizinischer Versorgung,
Abwasser, Straßen, sonst was.
Es sollte nicht primär darum gehen,
dass die Sachen
ultrawirtschaftlich sind, sondern
dass man eine ordentliche Versorgung
für die Bevölkerung hat.
Ich meine, dass man das Ganze anstrebt,
dass das kostendeckend ist, ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Und dass zumindest auf den ersten Blick
ein privater Laden wie die Telekom
Kohle machen will, ist auch okay.
Aber da fehlen einfach
die Rahmenbedingungen.
... nicht.
Der Glasfaserausbau in Deutschland
ist Aufgabe privatwirtschaftlicher
Unternehmen. Der Staat darf mit
Fördermitteln nur dann eingreifen, wenn
an einem Ort zwei Dinge zusammenkommen.
Erstens, die Internetgeschwindigkeit
liegt unter 30 Megabit
pro Sekunde, die sogenannte
Aufgreifschwelle. Zweitens,
kein privates Unternehmen plant
konkret auf eigene Kosten einen
Ausbau, das sogenannte
Marktversagen.
Tatsächlich hängt Deutschland beim Glasfaserausbau
so wie hier... Ich meine, wir...
Wir sind seit 10 Jahren...
Seit 10 Jahren
regen wir uns
allesamt darüber auf, wie schlecht
das ist. Und von Jahr zu Jahr
regt man sich weiter darüber auf, wie schlecht das ist.
Aber im Prinzip wird an den
grundlegenden Sachen, warum das
so schlecht ist, warum das so schleppend geht, überhaupt nichts gemacht.
Das fängt ja
schon damit an, dass wenn
Vodafone bei der einen Seite
aufgebuddelt hat, dass dann manchmal
die Telekom ankommt und zwei Wochen später
wieder aufbuddelt. Oder aber umgedreht, die
Telekom nicht aufbuddeln darf, weil Vodafone...
Das ist komplett
bescheuert, Alter.
... der sächsischen Vordorf deutlich hinterher.
Nur rund 10%
der Haushalte hatten 2019
einen Glasfaseranschluss
verfügbar. Weit weniger als...
Die sollen mal nach Südkorea gucken, was das angeht.
Südkorea ist vielleicht nicht ganz so groß, hat vielleicht nicht ganz so
viele Einwohner. Ich glaube, es sind ungefähr ein Drittel oder so
an Einwohner und Fläche. Aber da funktioniert
das wunderbar. Und bei uns ist
das halt... Bei uns ist das absolut
kek... kek... kek... da... da...
da reicht kek W nicht.
Das ist kek quadruple U
ist das... ist das
bei uns.
Südkorea macht auch
Überlandleitung. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung im Detail, wie das Südkorea macht,
aber es scheint ja ganz gut zu funktionieren.
Schließlich wollte die Bundesregierung bereits
bis 2018
alle Haushalte mit mindestens 50
Megabit pro Sekunde versorgen.
Ja, ja, das hab ich ja sogar
50 Mal retweetet.
Was, 10% der Leute? Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Äh, Südkorea... Südkorea
hat 50 Millionen Einwohner
oder so. Wir haben 80 Millionen. So ein großer Unterschied ist das
nicht.
Das hab ich 20.000 Mal
immer mal wieder retweetet.
Diese Ankündigung. Und hab mich drüber
lustig gemacht.
Ja, über welche
Technik man das letztendlich macht, ist ja fast
egal. Ähm, das wird
denen mit die 2 Mbit haben
auch egal sein. Mein Glasfaser wäre natürlich
Premium. Da geht in Zukunft sogar noch
ein bisschen mehr. Ähm, wenn da Coax-Leitungen
liegen, ist das auch okay. Aber du hast so viele
ländliche Gebiete, wo du
wo du, wenn du Glück hast, Matthias
Light kriegst. Wenn man sich diese
Karte hier anguckt,
die zeige ich ja gerne.
Äh,
gerade im Osten, wenn du da mal ran suchst,
ist der komplett im
Arsch, ne?
Oh, der ist neu. Die haben den neu
gebaut. Guck mal hier, der sieht jetzt moderner aus.
Coax ist halt der Ping-Scheiß.
Warum?
Oh, was hat das mit dem Ping doch wurscht?
Äh, also über
50 Mbit, alle Techniken. Also wir wollen nicht
alle Techniken, wir wollen Leitungsgebunden haben.
So. Und gerade, und gerade
hier im Osten, also man sieht ja schon allein
hier, ne? 75 Mbit.
Also, das müsste er eigentlich schon mal
flächendeckend 95 Mbit.
Leitungsgebunden, ähm,
50 Mbit plus sollte eigentlich schon
mal 95% plus
sein. Ne? Weil ja bis 2018
50 Mbit für jeden. Wissen wir ja.
So. Aber gerade wenn man hier mal
so im Osten ranzoomt
und wartet bis das
lädt, das ist der Witz.
Gerade wenn du hier ein bisschen
ländlicher reinguckst, das ist ja wirklich
äh, ganz, ganz
grausam hier. Ah, gucken wir mal weiter.
Der Chat ist im Weg.
Ah.
Ist zu spät.
Ne, Starlink wird da auch nichts großartiges dran ändern.
Haha, das ist so geil.
Es ist so geil.
Es interessiert einfach
keine Sau, dass man es
verkackt hat. Also,
diese, diese 50 Mbit bis
2018, das ist ja nicht
das erste Breitbandziel, was wir verschissen
haben. So. Und hier, man
macht einfach, man macht einfach weiter.
Ohne darauf einzugehen.
Normalerweise müsste man eigentlich
sagen, okay, warum
haben wir dann 50 Mbit bis
2018 nicht geschafft?
Und warum haben wir das bis heute nicht geschafft?
Aber nein, das macht man nicht.
Man sagt einfach, ja
bis 2025 Gigabit.
Was ein, was ein
Scheißgelaber, Alter.
Wo wir wieder bei dem eigentlichen Thema sind.
Ähm.
Wo ich, äh,
mich das letzte Mal im Stream ja
irgendwie fast eine Stunde drüber ausgelassen habe.
Du kannst dich einfach nicht darauf verlassen, dass
irgendeiner was für dich macht.
Leider gibt es so, sowas,
sowas hier, wo du selbst
relativ wenig machen kannst.
Ja. Aber in allen Bereichen, wo du
was selbst machen kannst, ist es besser, du machst
das selbst, anstatt dass du dich darauf verlässt, dass irgendwann mal
ein anderer was für dich macht. Ist leider mittlerweile
so. Man muss, man muss selbst
gucken, wo man bleibt. Ja. Es wäre mir auch
lieber, wenn es anders wäre, aber man kann es ja nicht, nicht, nicht.
Echt absolut null noch drauf verlassen.
Es gibt, es gibt immer wieder
Leute, die ankommen und sagen, ja, wenn ihr uns
wählt, dann machen wir was ganz Tolles für euch und
im Strich passiert gar nichts. Ja, egal. Egal
welche Farbe, es ist eigentlich vollkommen egal.
25 aufbauen.
Das wurde auch im Koalitionsvertrag
so festgeschrieben. Ja, der
Koalitionsvertrag interessiert ja eh keinen.
Glasfaser in jeder
Region und jeder Gemeinde.
Möglichst direkt bis zum Haus.
Bereits in 5 Jahren soll also
ein Glasfasernetz aufgebaut sein.
Zu dem jeder Bürger Zugang hat.
Das entspräche 100%
der Haushalte. Mitte
2019 hatten jedoch gerade mal
10,4% der Haushalte
Zugang zu reinen Glasfaseranschlüssen.
Da gibt es noch viel zu tun.
Chuck96
13 Monate. Dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription.
Schön.
Erreicht die Politik
diesmal das gesetzte Ziel? Nein. Nein.
Aber Krischer ist Bundestagsabgeordneter.
So muss man doch nicht mal Hellseher sein.
Wir haben nicht einmal,
nicht eines unserer
Breitbandziele der letzten, frag mich nicht,
20 Jahre erreicht.
Weiß nicht, ob es das schon so lange gibt, ehrlich gesagt.
Wir haben es noch nicht einmal geschafft.
Warum sollen wir das bis 2015...
Das ist vor allem jetzt sogar das unrealistischste
von...
Ja, Twinko, die Rahmenbedingungen sind teilweise
für die Bundesregierung für völlig unrealistisch.
Wenn wir mit dem Tempo
weitermachen, würde das noch 100 Jahre
dauern, bis wir dieses Ziel erreichen.
Also ich glaube, das ist eher eine
Traumtänzerstrategie.
Ein Grund für den schleppenden Breitbandausbau?
Das Förderprogramm der Regierung
funktioniert nicht, sagt Krischer.
Insgesamt stehen ca. 11 Milliarden
Euro zur Verfügung.
Bewilligt für konkrete Projekte sind
davon gerade mal 6,6 Milliarden.
Das hat sogar dazu
geführt, dass ich früher mal die Piraten
Partei gewählt habe, wegen dem Kram.
So vor, frag mich nicht,
15, 10 Jahren
oder so, als es die noch gab
und mich außer diesem Thema
Technik sonst nichts interessiert hat.
Ich glaube, die gibt es gar nicht mehr mittlerweile.
Von denen habe ich eh
nichts mehr gehört.
Das erfolgloseste Bundesprogramm, das es lange
gegeben hat. Das Geld ist kaum abgeflossen.
Tatsächlich sind seit 2015
nur rund 566
Millionen Euro ausgezahlt worden.
Das ist ja nix!
Das milliardenschwere Förderprogramm
hat einen Haken. Das Geld darf
nicht eingesetzt werden, sobald eine
Minimalversorgung von 30 Megabit
pro Sekunde vorliegt. Ja Moment, wie passt
das damit zusammen, dass wir 50 Mbit
für alle haben wollen bis 2018?
Schwelle soll zwar auf
100 Megabit pro Sekunde erhöht
werden, doch auch diese Übertragungsrate
sei Lichtjahre von
einer Gigabit-Gesellschaft entfernt,
sagen Experten.
Ganz ehrlich,
Gigabit
mag ja schön und gut sein.
Ehrlich gesagt, kaum
jemand, also man muss natürlich in die Zukunft
denken, aber aktuell ist es so, kaum
jemand hat das
wirklich nötig, dass das Gigabit sein
müsste. Viel wichtiger wäre eigentlich,
dass man wirklich mal
so eine
annehmbare Basis hat, sagen wir,
von meinetwegen sogar 50
Mbit. Ich wäre ja eher für 100 Mbit.
Wo du dich
dann aber auch wirklich drauf verlassen kannst,
dass du die kriegst.
Weil was hast du denn davon, wenn
die, die jetzt eh schon
einen super Ausbau haben, irgendwo mitten in Frankfurt
oder so, wenn die demnächst dann
auch noch zusätzlich ein bisschen
mehr Gigabit bekommen. Also sprich, die Leute,
die jetzt 400 Mbit plus jetzt schon bekommen,
kriegen dann halt Gigabit. Ich meine, ich habe da kein Problem
mit dich. Ich würde es ja mittlerweile
bei Vodafone auch kriegen, aber
wichtig ist, dass
du doch mal auch guckst, dass die, die jetzt
nichts bekommen, die
Bibelleute, wenn die 2 Mbit haben,
dass die mal irgendwie
eine ordentliche Basis bekommen, wo du was
machen kannst. Und man glaubt das gar nicht,
was Corona bewirkt hat
hier so gesellschaftsmäßig.
Jetzt nicht, also gerade durch
Corona wird diese
Mangelausbauerscheinung,
die wir da haben,
jetzt erstmal deutlich. Aber
was das
bei vielen Unternehmen und Leuten möglich
gemacht hat, was sie gar nicht für möglich gehalten haben,
dass sie jetzt zum Beispiel eben von daheim in die
Schule gehen müssen, dass sie von daheim arbeiten müssen,
dass sie überhaupt relativ viele Sachen machen
müssen, so wie es,
weil sie es nicht mehr so machen können,
wie sie es vorher gemacht haben,
da sieht man mal, was alles möglich ist
und was alles geht
in der heutigen Zeit schon, was man
bloß einfach nicht gemacht hat.
So, und dementsprechend fällt jetzt halt
besonders stark auf, scheiße,
manche Sachen gehen halt mit unserem
Steinzeit-Internet nicht.
Es gibt es sich meist ruhig und beschaulich,
mit viel Sinn für Tradition.
Ein Heimatmuseum
bewahrt die gute alte Zeit.
Etwas zu museal
geht es allerdings beim Thema
Breitbandversorgung zu.
Viele Bewohner, die wir fragen, sind unzufrieden
mit ihrer Internetverbindung.
Sie bricht einfach ab oder
der Fernseher hört dann irgendwann mal auf,
weil, ja, kein Internet
empfangen im Moment ist.
Würden Sie sich wünschen, dass das besser funktioniert?
Gerne, aber für den gleichen Preis.
Ich bin Informatiker.
Ich arbeite in der Videobildverarbeitung.
Benachteiligungen erlebe ich dadurch ...
Schon ein richtig krasser Let's Player.
... Datenmenge, mit denen ich arbeite,
die ich im Prinzip offline
herunterladen muss.
Bedeutet irgendwelche
halbstündige, stündige Wartezeiten
bei großen Datenmengen natürlich.
Diese Probleme
wollte Bürgermeister Sven Waigt
schon vor Jahren lösen.
2014 plant er ...
Der Louis Vuitton-Anzug hat es gereicht.
... zu beantragen, um hier ein kommunales
Glasfasernetz zu verlegen.
Vorher wurden alle Netzbetreiber gefragt,
ob sie in der Region eigene
Ausbaupläne haben.
Und hatten dann mit der Telekom
besprochen, wollt ihr was tun?
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt hat die Telekom gesagt,
nein, wir machen nichts.
Ja, das kann die Telekom gut.
... dem Landkreis 2014 mit.
In diesem Zusammenhang werden wir
gegebenenfalls auch in dieser Region
in den kommenden drei Jahren Gebiete
im Eigenausbau mit Breitband
erschließen.
Ach du Scheiße.
Vielmehr Relativierung in einem Satz
geht doch kaum.
Alter, was für ein Satz.
The fuck, was ist das?
Ich hab was gesagt, um nichts zu sagen.
In diesem Zusammenhang werden wir
gegebenenfalls auch in dieser Region
in den kommenden drei Jahren Gebiete
im Eigenausbau mit Breitband erschließen.
Das heißt im Endeffekt so,
vielleicht, wenn wir Lust haben,
gegebenenfalls hab ich morgen auch
eine Million Abos auf YouTube.
Welcher Fall muss denn gegeben sein dafür?
Gegebenenfalls krieg ich jetzt
250 Giftsubs.
Welche Fall denn?
Gegebenenfalls
gifte ich am Ende des Streams
50 Subs an den Chat.
... unsere derzeitigen Planungen
sind aber noch nicht...
In diesem Zusammenhang.
... dass wir bereits jetzt verbindliche Anregungen
dazu machen können.
Keine Ahnung wann, so lautet
die Auskunft der Telekom für die Gemeinde,
die daraufhin beginnt, ihr eigenes
Glasfasernetz zu verlegen.
Danach baut die Telekom ihr Netz
darüber.
Später hat dann die Telekom mit der Vectoring-Technik
diesen Verteilerkasten angesteuert
und die ganze Straße wurde an der Seite
nochmal aufgemacht.
Bei der Modernisierung des Kupfernetzes,
dem sogenannten Vectoring, liegen
Glasfaserkabel nur bis zum Verteilerkasten.
Ab dort werden Daten
über alte Telefonleitungen aus
Service ins Haus übertragen.
Vectoring kann Daten mit einer
Geschwindigkeit bis zu 100 Megabit pro Sekunde
übertragen. Ein Zehntel der
Geschwindigkeit des kommunalen
Glasfasernetzes. Doch das kann nicht
fertiggestellt werden, sagt Bürgermeister
Weigt.
Dann sitzt er im Graben.
Dann würde ich sagen einfach, ich bin gewerblich.
Manchmal muss man
irgendwie den Scheiß austricksen,
selbst wenn es fragwürdig ist.
Ich meine, es reicht wahrscheinlich
nicht, wenn du einfach sagst, ich bin gewerblich.
Du musst dir dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie noch was
aus den Fingern sagen. Ich könnte das sagen, ja.
Dann würde ich einfach meinen Zettel,
wo ich die Firma angemeldet habe, würde ich
sagen, hier, bam.
Gewerblich, äh, gut ist.
Aber,
gut, bei den meisten geht's wahrscheinlich
nicht.
Hab ich das richtig
verstanden? Hier liegt also ein Glasfaserkasten
in der Straße.
Du kannst ja, also Gewerbeanmelden ist, ich hab mir das
auch viel
komplexer vorgestellt. Du musst im Prinzip
einen Zettel ausfüllen, ja, und abgeben.
Also ist es, ganz ehrlich,
hätte ich die Auswahl,
2 Mbit oder gewerbliches
Gigabit, ähm, dann würde ich
ein Gewerbeanmelden. Da mache ich dann
irgendeinen Mist auf, und gut ist so.
Wobei, einen Unterschied
gibt's. Du musst, glaube ich, danach
eine Steuererklärung machen.
Vorher ist das ja freiwillig.
Ich glaube, danach musst du eine Steuererklärung
machen. Musst übrigens auch wieder
demnächst Steuererklärung machen.
Das geht mir immer voll auf. Ich muss
die nicht machen, ich hab ja zum Glück einen Steuerberater, der das
macht, aber ich muss Zeugs zusammensuchen.
Aber die Bürger
dürfen nicht angeschlossen werden.
Es ist relativ komplex, das Förderverfahren, es gibt die
sogenannte Aufgriffsschwelle, das heißt, ab wann
sagt man politisch, gibt's eine Unterversorgung,
und nur wenn die vorliegt, darf man
auch als öffentliche Hand eingreifen.
Wenn die nicht vorliegt, darf man
auch nicht abhängen.
Das ist doch
der Witz wieder.
Daran sieht man doch schon mal
den ganzen Widerspruch.
Vorne raus wird marketingtechnisch
gelabert, 50 Mbit für jeden
bis 2018,
und die Förderbedingungen sind 30
Mbit.
Das ist doch absolut krasser Widerspruch.
Das ergibt überhaupt
keinen Sinn.
Nur wo das der Fall ist,
darf ein Glasfasernetz mit öffentlichen
Geldern gebaut werden.
30 Mbit aber erreichen oft auch
die alten Kupfernetze der Telekom.
So blockieren Vorgaben der Politik
und vermeintliche Geschäftsinteressen
der Telekom den schnelleren
Glasfaserausbau, wie in Karlsdorf
Neuthardt.
Wir haben die Deutsche Telekom AG um ein
Interview gebeten. Eine Antwort
erhalten wir schriftlich. Das Unternehmen
widerspricht den Aussagen von
Bürgermeister Waigt. Wörtlich heißt es,
die Telekom trifft ihre
Ausbauentscheidungen unabhängig
und anhand von wirtschaftlichen Kriterien.
Ein Bezug zum Glasfaserausbau
der Kommune ist nicht gegeben.
Im Prinzip kann die Telekom alles sagen.
Bevor die Gemeinde
Karlsdorf Neuthardt eigene Ausbaupläne
hatte. Deswegen hat ihnen die Telekom
vorher geschrieben, dass sie das nicht
planen. Klingt logisch.
Kommunaler Glasfaserausbau
mit Steuergeldern bezahlt.
Das wäre eigentlich auch eine Option.
Ich weiß ja, ich hab ehrlich gesagt, ich kann das nicht
abschätzen, wie teuer sowas ist.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob man da irgendwie Geld sammeln könnte
und das
so finanzieren könnte. Ich hab keine Ahnung,
ob das realistisch ist.
Also ich hab
wirklich keine Ahnung.
Mal angenommen,
man würde irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, jeder bezahlt 50 Euro,
das reicht nicht.
Jeder bezahlt 500 Euro.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie groß so eine Gemeinde
ist.
500 Euro, was haben die da für Einwohner?
10.000?
Also wenn du 10.000 Einwohner hast
und jeder hast du 5 Millionen.
Ich glaube, da kommst du nicht so weit
mit, oder? Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung,
was das kostet.
Mit Richtfunk. Ja, das ist natürlich auch
eine Option. Da habe ich
gar keine Ahnung von. Aber es müssen ja nicht unbedingt
Glasfaserleitungen sein.
... behindert. Kein Einzelfall,
sagt der Bundestagsabgeordnete Oliver
Krischer. Das Vorgehen der Telekom
habe System.
Das nennt man Überbauung.
Das ist eine Strategie der Telekom,
die an ganz, ganz vielen Stellen
stattfindet, wo sie ihre Marktmacht
im Grunde genommen nutzt,
ihre Macht über die vorhandene Infrastruktur,
das Kupferkabel, um damit am
Ende den Glasfaserausbau
zu verhindern, indem sie einfach
den neuen Wettbewerbern die Kunden wegschnappt.
Ja, mal ganz davon abgesehen, also
er blamet da jetzt ein bisschen
die Telekom.
Die Telekom gehört
zu glaub 30% dem Staat.
Also so rein
nur auf die Telekom
zeigen, da müsst ihr auch auf euch selbst
zeigen, ja. Also
das ist auch die Rahmenbedingungen
wichtig.
Telekom kann das
nur machen, solange sie das machen kann.
Exzellenzsatz, ne. Die Telekom kann das nur
machen, solange sie es machen kann. Ich sollte vielleicht besser
sagen, die Telekom kann das nur machen, solange sie das machen darf.
Ich habe selber im
Beirat der Bundesnetzagentur erlebt,
wie die Telekom Lobbyarbeit betrieben
hat, dass dieses
Kupfernetz weiter als Alternative
gesehen und gefördert wird.
Es ist ja aktuell auch
die einzige Alternative in vielen Bereichen,
die jetzt aktuell direkt
verfügbar ist, ja.
Aber
ob jetzt die letzten Meter ins Haus Kupfer sind,
Glas sind oder sonst was, ist
jetzt unmittelbar, man für die Zukunft
sei es mal dahingestellt, für die Zukunft natürlich
wäre das Beste, wenn jeder einen Glasfaser
Anschluss im Haus hätte. Unmittelbar ist
das nicht verkehrt, ja. Aber
da musst du zumindest
den Infrastrukturausbau
bis vors Haus so weit
betreiben, dass du die letzten Meter
mit Kupfer ordentlich überbrücken kannst.
Überbrücken kannst. Und
du kannst es ja nicht komplett verteufeln,
weil ansonsten haben die Leute die Auswahl
ein Gigabit Glasfaser oder
zwei Mbit nichts im Endeffekt, das kann es ja auch nicht
sein, ja. Wenn man das noch
weiterverwendet, ich würde das gar nicht mal
so sehr verteufeln, um zu sagen,
alles Kupfer muss weg, nee, nee.
Man sollte das eher als
Technologie sehen, die jetzt gerade
verfügbar ist, wo man auch
durchaus noch weiter investieren und forschen muss,
aber für die zukünftigen
Sachen ist natürlich klar,
umso mehr Glasfaser, umso besser.
Aber du musst
ja dafür, dass du das ordentlich benutzen kannst,
trotzdem weiter ausbauen.
Total. Das ist
mit eine zentrale Ursache, worum es
in Deutschland mit dem Glasfaserausbau nicht weitergeht.
Da hätten sie doch jetzt nochmal den Typ fragen sollen.
Da hätten sie den nochmal gefragt.
Warum, warum,
warum sind die jetzt nicht mit der
Aussage von der Telekom nochmal zu dem Typ
gegangen und haben gesagt, okay,
die Telekom hat das geantwortet, was sagen sie dazu?
Die Antwort hätte mich jetzt wirklich
mal interessiert, ja.
Ist das hier ein Aufwachestream oder ein
Aufwachestream?
Wir sind alle schon, was das angeht.
Wir sind sowas von woke, wie man
heute sagt, also wer wacher kann es ja
gar nicht mal sein.
Bis 2020 sind Bautrupps unterwegs
und schließen die Häuser an das zukunftsfähige
Gigabit-Netz an.
Bevor die Stadt mit dem Glasfaserausbau
begonnen hat, wurden wie vorgeschrieben
alle Telekommunikationsanbieter
gefragt, ob sie hier eigene
Pläne für einen Breitbandausbau haben.
Wir haben gefragt, wer kann das machen?
Es haben sich konkret
keine Leute dazu gemeldet,
also keine Firmen dazu gemeldet.
Es gab sehr nebulöse
Willensbekundungen.
Ja, das machen die wahrscheinlich
absichtlich. Wahrscheinlich ist das
Absicht, dass man sowas Vages erzählt.
Oh, da, der will's
aber auch wissen.
Die machen das absichtlich, dass man da sowas
Unkonkretes erzählt,
dass man im Nachhinein sagen kann,
ja wieso, wir haben uns doch geäußert dazu,
klar wollen wir.
... die uns aber nicht weit genug gingen.
Und daraufhin haben wir gesagt, müssen wir selber machen.
Und genau das passiert
hier gerade. Bis Ende
2020 sollen alle Haushalte
an das schnelle Internet angeschlossen sein.
Doch nun gibt es
ein Problem. Vor einigen Monaten
hat die Telekom begonnen, ihr altes
Netz durch Vectoring aufzurüsten.
Dort, wo die Stadt bereits ihr
Glasfasernetz verlegt hat, wird nun
die Straße erneut aufgerissen.
Dabei hätte die Telekom die Leerrohre
der Stadt gegen Pachten nutzen können,
anstatt ihr eigenes Netz darüber
zu bauen.
Die Telekom wird nun zur Konkurrenz
für das kommunale Netz.
Da kostet ein Glasfaseranschluss
49,90 Euro pro Monat
und bietet dafür eine Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit
von 500 Megabit pro Sekunde.
Die Telekom bietet
einen Vectoringanschluss
für 43,82 Euro an
mit einer Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit
von gerade mal 100 Megabit
pro Sekunde.
Je weniger Kunden Glasfaser buchen,
desto länger dauert es,
bis die Stadt das Netz abbezahlt hat.
Dadurch fehlt Geld, das an anderer
Stelle gebraucht wird.
Die Telekom weiß, warum sie in
Oebesfelde-Weferlingen ihr Kupfernetz
parallel zum Glasfaserausbau der Stadt
erneuert. Schriftlich teilt das Unternehmen
mit, man habe die Ausbauabsichten
bereits vor Jahren bekannt gegeben,
doch die Stadt hätte die erforderlichen
Baugenehmigungen verzögert.
Deswegen kommen da immer so
äh
vage Aussagen, dass man sich auf sowas
zurückziehen kann.
Weiter heißt es, im Zuge des
Ausbaus des Glasfasernetzes
durch die Stadt, hätten wir uns eine
Koordinierung der Baumaßnahmen gewünscht.
Die Verweigerung...
Meine Frage, vielleicht haben wir
jemanden, der sich auskennt. Also mal angenommen,
mal angenommen,
ich grabe jetzt in meiner Straße
oder in meinem Ort
alle Straßen auf,
lege da Glasfaser rein,
schließe alle Häuser an, so.
Dann habe ich ja immer noch das Problem,
ich muss ja irgendwie mich
irgendwo anschließen, ja.
Rein Glasfaserleitungen, die einfach in der Straße liegen,
kannst du ja nicht ins Internet.
So, bei der Telekom,
bei Vodafone und sonst was, ist klar,
ja, ähm,
die machen das selbst.
Da muss ich, ich muss doch dann
irgendwie gucken,
dass ich, dass ich in irgendeiner
Art und Weise zu irgendeiner,
zu einem etwas größeren Knotenpunkt
noch hinlege meine Leitung, wo ich
mich anschließen kann, oder?
Also irgendwie muss ich ja ans Internet kommen.
Und ich könnte mir halt
vorstellen, dass so am Arsch der Welt hier
liegen, dass das auch ein bisschen weg,
ein bisschen weiter weg ist.
Ich habe da, das habe ich mir auch keine große
Angelegenheit, weil in Frankfurt ist das kein Problem.
In Frankfurt hast du, wo du, wo du hinguckst,
irgendwelche Leerrohre, wo Zeugs drin liegt.
Das läuft da so unter Dark Fiber oder sowas,
was jetzt, das ist kein, kein,
kein schwarzes Licht oder so,
das sind einfach Glasfaser, die da liegen und unbenutzt sind.
Das ist dann Dark Fiber.
Man muss ja irgendwo angebunden werden.
Ja.
Aber trotzdem,
du kannst, du kannst,
das ist ja eigentlich das,
was die Politik in allen Bereichen machen muss.
Du kannst es nicht unbedingt selbst
direkt machen, kann ja schlecht irgendwie einer hingehen
und die Schaufel schwingen, aber wenn er will, kann er das schon.
Du musst die passenden Rahmenbedingungen für das schaffen,
wo du willst,
dass sich das in diese Richtung entwickelt.
Und das waren wir halt auch schon seit 20 Jahren nicht.
Den kann ich mich noch erinnern.
Als Aktiengesellschaft muss die Telekom...
Wie krass die da damals
die Leute gebetet haben mit Telekom-Aktien.
...nicht mehr dem Gemeinwohl dienen.
Jetzt heißt der Auftrag,
Geld verdienen. Und das klappt.
2019 macht das Unternehmen
3,9 Milliarden Euro Gewinn.
Und das freut wiederum
den Bund.
Mit knapp 32 Prozent Aktienanteilen
ist der Staat größter
Gesellschafter der Telekom und kassierte
allein in den letzten fünf Jahren
knapp 1,4 Milliarden Euro
Dividenden.
An der Universität
Duisburg-Essen forscht und lehrt
Professor Thorsten Gerpott
seit über 15 Jahren im Bereich
Telekommunikationswirtschaft.
Das machen die in solchen Fernsehbeiträgen...
Das machen die gerne Intro,
da lassen sie Leute immer einen Gang lang laufen
und filmen das. Oder so sitzen Leute
an Rechner und die dürfen dann irgendwie
ganz, ganz interessiert in den
Bildschirm gucken und irgendwas auf
ihrer Tastatur tippen.
So nach dem Motto, wir haben ihn bei der Arbeit
gefilmt.
Die Telekom ist letztlich ein privatwirtschaftliches Unternehmen,
muss sich nach privatwirtschaftlichen Maßstäben orientieren
und das kann man ihr dann eben auch nicht
vorwerfen. Und wenn halt eine Gemeinde
ausbaut, dann ist das für die Telekom
so, dass ein neuer Wettbewerber
austritt. Und von daher finde ich es völlig
legitim, wenn man eben sagt, oh,
da tritt jetzt Wettbewerber auf, da müssen
wir auch was tun, sonst gewinnen wir keine
Kunden mehr, sonst verlieren wir unsere Bestandskunden.
Es geht um Deutschlands Zukunft.
Höchste Zeit, dass
der politisch versprochene Glasfaser...
Irgendwie war der Schnitt jetzt ein bisschen
hart, oder?
Der Typ hat irgendwas gesagt und jetzt geht's...
Hä?
Der Beitrag
muss fertig werden, der war schon zu lang.
Ja.
Ja, passt ja. Also...
Der Beitrag an sich ging ja.
Was 100
Betriebssysteme von einem USD
extrem multiboot.
Irgendjemand hat gepostet, ich soll mir das mal
angucken. Gucken, ob das was taugt.
Gekürzt für HDHS
YouTube normal 30... Echt jetzt?
Oder ist das ein Witz?
Ich kann mir nämlich echt vorstellen, dass das stimmt.
Ich habe einige Tipps für euch, die
so lustig... Oh, ne!
Das sind die,
das sind die mit dem Windows
Optimierungspack.
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Das sind die mit diesem komischen Windows Optimierungspack.
Wo wir uns mal... Könnt ihr
euch noch dran erinnern? Dieses Windows
Optimierungspack mit PowerShell?
Mit PowerShell GUI?
Wisst ihr noch mit PowerShell GUI?
Das PowerShell
GUI.
Und wie das programmiert war, das war grausam.
Okay, ich skipp mal kurz
durch. Okay,
das ist bestimmt cringe.
...interessant sind und so geheim...
Was zum Teufel ist mit der Kamera
für... Oh, egal, ich halte jetzt die Klappe.
In meinen Livestreams habe ich öfters gesagt,
pass auf... Sag mal, macht der einen Schnitt?
20 Sekunden, nee, alle 2 Sekunden.
... ist ne geile
Idee für die Leute, die es nicht wissen.
...
Das ist wie mal eine Zeit lang, als Unge noch nicht nur Reaction-Videos gemacht hat, wo jeder am Anfang mit seiner Kamera gemacht hat.
Kannst du dir noch einer dran erinnern?
Jetzt gibt es so ein paar YouTube-Sachen, die werde ich nicht verstehen.
Such doch nach dem Programm und nicht nach dem Kerl.
Naja, so Dinger, nee, nach dem Programm muss ich nicht suchen.
Es gibt zig so Multiboot-Sachen.
Das ist ja nicht das Einzige.
So, was haben wir jetzt hier noch Schönes?
We fixed Windows 10.
Was ist, okay, das ist, wie dat mit, ein ziemlich übertriebener Titel.
Ich hab da so meine Zweifel, dass Microsoft sich überhaupt auch nur ansatzweise für interessieren wird.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, was fixen sie denn?
Wahrscheinlich werfen sie irgendwelche Sachen runter oder so.
Wir haben uns über die Privatsphäre von Windows 10 interessiert, oder, äh, seit einiger Zeit nicht mehr, aber, äh, während ihr auf Linux versucht habt, könnt ihr einfach nicht aufhören zu springen.
Vielleicht gibt es eine Software, die euch helfen wird.
Für die meisten Leute funktioniert das auch überhaupt nicht.
Die meisten Kack-Noobs, vor allem, wenn ihr ein paar Spiele spielen wollt, ist mit Linux, kommt, kommt, kommt sogar nicht weit.
Ihr braucht nicht richtig viel Zeit.
Und das sage ich als jemand, der mit Linux sein Geld verdient.
Ihr seid nur ein Fan von Windows.
Außer den Privatsphären-Problemen.
Was könnt ihr tun?
Warum nicht?
Was?
Gaming funktioniert nicht gescheit unter Linux.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, du möchtest nur Super-Tux-Karten spielen.
Diese Apps verringern deine Verbindung in real-time.
Sie werden von Sicherheits-Proben genutzt, um die Meldung von Meldungen zu kontrollieren, Bandwürfe zu blockieren, Wäscher zu entdecken, und zusätzliche Aktivitäten zu entdecken.
Nimm 25% aus, wenn du Linus-Code nutzt.
Hat einer von euch mal WSL 2 benutzt?
Ja, wenn man keine Linux-VM verwenden kann oder will, ist WSL 2 tatsächlich nicht übel.
Es laufen 11.000, äh, 11,5k Games auf Linux, ja.
Äh, ich weiß nicht, ob das viel oder wenig ist.
Wenn ich mir angucke, wie viel Schrott es auf Steam gibt, da gibt's wahrscheinlich auch Millionen Games.
Und davon ist vielleicht 1% spielenswert.
Sagt die reine Anzahl von was irgendwo irgendwie läuft nicht wirklich viel aus.
Erstens ist die Frage von wie viel.
Und dann ist auch die Frage, wie gut, was versteht man unter Laufen.
Und spätestens, wenn's, äh, an die größeren Titel geht, mit, äh, von VR fangen wir mal gar nicht an.
Aber rein um Multiplayer, und das ist ja nun mal was, was eine riesen User-Base hat.
Und Multiplayer, gar Multiplayer.
Gar, gar Multiplayer mit Anti-Cheat oder gar, gar Spiele mit, äh, Kopierschutz oder sowas.
Da wird's schon orschdünn unter Linux.
Wow!
Äh, ist ja gut, äh.
Ich hab auch nicht gesagt, dass jedes Spiel nicht funktioniert, aber du hast damit, äh, Probleme.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, wie's zum Beispiel mittlerweile mit, äh, was nennen wir mal, wie...
Keine Ahnung, wie sieht's mit Overwatch aus?
Overwatch Multiplayer. Weiß nicht, wie gut das mittlerweile auf Linux geht.
...ameliorated edition, a small project that's actually been around since all the way back in 2017.
Now, not a whole lot of information is available surrounding who is actually behind it,
but some old links point to Actrons, a 90s kid who specifically calls out
technology, social science, philosophy, psychology and neurology,
film and anime analysis and cringe...
...as their topics of interest.
Ameliorated edition seems to be an offshoot of their Windows 10 install script, which originally...
Wozu brauch ich sowas?
...merely disabled things like Windows Update and made adjustments to Windows Explorer.
As newer Windows Builds came out, though, with more deeply integrated telemetry,
a more direct approach was necessary to stop Windows from bloody phoning home and giving them all my...
Das Video ist doch übelst laut!
...information!
...ameliorated edition straight up removes Windows Update, Cortana, Activation...
Ja, warum man Windows Updates deaktivieren soll, verstehe ich auch nicht.
Ganz viele dieser Guides sagen immer, man soll Windows Updates deaktivieren.
Aber warum?
...Microsoft Edge, Windows Media Player and all Apex UWP applications from the install.
Not disabled. Removed.
No longer present.
What that means is there is a total size reduction of roughly two gigs.
Now, of course, removing such deeply rooted components requires the introduction of replacements in certain cases.
Killing Cortana...
Okay, okay, also, jetzt mal nur mal von der Logik her.
Das heißt, ich finde es doof, was Microsoft macht.
Dementsprechend baue ich es aus und ersetze es durch irgendwas, was noch viel unsicherer ist, oder was?
What the fuck?
Also, ich traue Microsoft nicht, aber ich traue irgendwelchen random Dudes dann...
Weiß nicht, da bin ich ja mal...
Weiß nicht, mal gucken, was sie da machen.
...for example, cripples the start menu and especially Windows Search.
So, Classic Shell is used as a replacement.
And there's more that you'll have to give up, too.
DirectX 12 may not be fully supported due to Windows Updates...
Ja, kann ich gleich machen. Official Dark Eyes.
...and, of course, you're stuck without automatic updates.
In fact, the update process itself is a bit of a bear that requires you to disconnect from the Internet,
reactivate Windows Update temporarily and so on and so forth.
Suffice to say, while this version of Windows is focused on privacy, it's a little lighter on security.
Though, as the website claims, most of the commonly...
Warum?
...applications have been removed anyway, so...
Also, okay, okay, ich lasse ihn jetzt erstmal, bevor ich da jetzt wieder rummecke, aber...
...that point may be less important than you might think.
But enough talk, why don't we take a look for ourselves and see what else we're giving up in the name of improved privacy.
The first thing I noticed is that gone is Windows Mail.
Who uses Windows Mail?
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Windows Mail ist wirklich...
...absoluter Crap.
Da war sogar Outlook Express besser und das war schon Müll.
How crazy do you have to be to not just use a web browser for your mail?
Like, okay, Boomer, enjoy your Outlook, so no Windows Mail, no Windows Store and no Microsoft Edge.
All we've got down here is File Explorer.
That's it.
Actually, I'm noticing some more changes now, too.
Where's all the...
Where's all the drop-downs for File Explorer?
This feels like it's gonna be very, very different.
Das sieht, das sieht nicht nach Windows 10 aus.
Das sieht nach Windows 10 mit irgendwie Custom GUI aus, was versucht nach Windows 10 auszusehen.
Das ist ja, das ist ja, ist ja ganz, ganz, äh...
...vier...
...naja.
Also, we've got the classic Windows Vista and 7-Style Start Menu and of course, because there's no Edge, Anthony has helpfully thrown a Firefox shortcut on the desktop.
Actually...
The default is DuckDuckGo? Really?
Is that the Firefox default or is that Windows 10 ameliorated edition?
No, that's an ameliorated edition thing.
Actually, Firefox as well as Thunderbird, onlyOffice and VLC Media Player were all pre-installed by the operating system.
I've never heard of onlyOffice.
Apparently, it's a fork of...
Das ist OpenOffice, oder?
Ja.
It's very Microsoft Office looking.
Also, OpenOffice. Geh mal fort.
Minus Tech Tips. Wow, what's my...
Aber ich hab nicht nur was gegen OpenOffice.
Ich find jegliche Office-Software ist komplett überflüssig.
Außer, außer, au...
Die einzige Office, einzige Office-Anwendung, die ich für sinnvoll halte und die was bringt, ist Tabellenkalkulation.
Das ist für die Leute, die gerne irgendwelche, so die, so die Datenbank-Bastel-Umgebung für Leute, die nicht programmieren können.
Was benutzt du für Office?
Toll, gar nix.
Ich benutze einen Markdown-Editor und einen HTML-Format, das reicht.
Okay, we need to...
I need to update this.
Colton!
I'm here, what's up?
Ich mach keine PowerPoint in HTML.
Ich mach gar kein PowerPoint.
Ich mach einfach eine PDF.
Da machst du einen PDF-Reader im Fullscreen auf und gut, das...
That was so cool.
Can I summon people just by, like, saying their names?
Oh, ltdstore.com!
Oh nein, jetzt muss er wieder seine Unterhausen-Werbung machen.
Okay, what else can we try here?
Okay, so, where are, where's my file drop-down?
This is a modification to Windows Explorer called, I think...
Old Explorer?
Ähm...
Ah, okay, die lange Zahl im Chat.
Meistens verwende ich tatsächlich WIMP, wenn ich was auf der Arbeit mache.
Weil ich Markdown gar nicht mal so sehr zum...
Also, ich verwende Markdown nicht zum gleichzeitig Formatieren und mir Vorschau angucken.
Eigentlich hauptsächlich zum Highlighten von Text, weil es dann besser strukturiert aussieht.
Aber man kann es halt zu HTML rendern und sieht dann auch ganz gut aus.
Oder Visual Studio Code mit Vorschau.
Was?
Moment, was?
What the fuck was?
Oder Windows exploderxx wyndowes leading♥
orationone
Was?
W-w-w-was zur Hölle?
Weil einige der Änderungen, die sie zu Windows gemacht haben, auch den Explorer beeinflusst haben.
Also mussten sie den alten Explorer benutzen, um ihn zu patchen.
Nun kann ich dir sagen, dass es nur eine Sache gibt, die ich mich umsetzen würde.
Und das ist, wenn ich etwas suche und in diesen Folder gehe,
wenn ich auf den Folder klicke,
ihr Bastards, das ist nicht, was ich will.
Ich will, dass der Folder nach oben geht.
Wenn ich zurück in den vorigen...
Wenn ich Windows zu, zu wenig Windows-mäßig dafür...
Ich mache dann einfach, wenn ich irgendwie was machen will, in irgendeinem Ordner,
und dann mache ich einfach hier auf und gehe in den Ordner rein und mache dann was.
Aber ich weiß, das ist nicht der Windows-Weg.
Das macht der normale Windows-User so wahrscheinlich nicht.
Was hat das mit dem?
Nun, vieles davon ist Sachen, die mit dem Telemetry-Stuff verbunden sind.
Also Windows-Updates, Gaming, das Xbox-Stuff,
das wurde mit dem Telemetry-Stuff und dem Telefon-Haus verbunden.
Also, fast alles, was mit dem qualifiziert ist, wird auch getrennt.
Kann ich sogar einen Screensaver einstellen?
Ich denke, so. Es ist unter Display.
Ist es nicht?
Ich weiß nicht, ist es das?
Warte, hier ist es, hier ist es. Ich habe es, ich habe es.
Also, du kannst es nicht suchen?
Ich glaube, das wäre wahrscheinlich so, weil sie den normalen Suchen auch getrennt haben.
Ja, ohne Cortana würde Windows-Search einfach einfach sterben.
Ich wusste eigentlich nicht, dass dieser Bubble-Screensaver so cool war.
Das wusste ich auch nicht, dass Cortana und Windows-Suche zusammenhängen.
Das ist ein Windows-Vista-Klassiker hier.
Das war so cool.
Na, na, na.
Oh, 3D-Akzelerierung auf dem Desktop.
Der beste...
Der beste Windows...
Der beste Windows-Bildschirmschoner ist immer noch...
Moment.
Windows...
Alter, ich kann nicht mehr schreiben.
Das da.
Ist immer noch der beste Windows-Bildschirmschoner.
Ja.
3D-Pipes.
Das XP-Labyrinth.
Ja, das geht auch, aber...
Pipes...
Pipes ist der Beste, ey.
Oder Maze.
Maze.
Wobei das schon zu schlecht aussieht aus heutiger Sicht eigentlich.
Eigentlich...
Ich will nur diese Bubbles für Tage schauen.
Okay, Linus, was willst du uns jetzt sagen?
Wir sind alle über die Screensaver-Szene geflogen, als Spezies.
Das ist auch seltsam.
Windows-Tab...
...dass...
...die Dinge durchgezogen werden.
Okay, das Video ist langweilig.
Probieren irgendwie ein abgespecktes Windows 10 aus und wundern sich dann, dass es Windows 10 abgespeckt ist.
Okay.
Oh, Monka.
Corona.
Alter, die Platzierung passt echt ganz gut.
Also, wo soll ich jetzt mal hingehen?
ProtonDB.
Jetzt gucken wir uns mal ein paar aktuelle Sachen an, wie gut hier unter Linux laufen.
Okay, die Top 10% laufen schon mal gar nicht.
Das ist natürlich...
Gut.
CS läuft.
CS ist ja auch ein bisschen Vorzeigeprojekt davon, also das muss ja laufen.
So.
Schauen wir mal.
Also.
Wo kann man hier suchen?
Suchen.
Ja.
Suchen wir mal zum Beispiel...
Was ist denn...
Was ist denn jetzt gerade...
Was ist denn jetzt gerade neu?
Suchen wir mal.
Ähm.
Horizon Zero...
Wie schreibt man das?
Ich kann das nicht schreiben.
Broken.
Gut.
Schon das erste Game, wonach ich suche.
Broken.
Perfekt.
Geht gut los.
Äh.
Stimmt.
Fall Guys.
Bei Fall Guys könnte ich mir sogar vorstellen, dass das gut läuft.
Platinium.
Hoho.
Wahrscheinlich...
Wahrscheinlich läuft das...
Wahrscheinlich gibt es da sogar eine Native-Linux-Geschichte von, oder?
Ist...
Wie ist das?
Ist das...
Ah nee.
Ist Proton.
Okay.
Fall Guys ist Native.
Ja.
Dann ist klar.
Das ist ja logisch.
Wenn das jetzt laufen würde, wäre merkwürdig.
Ja.
Aber wie gesagt.
Das erste...
Das erste, nachdem ich gesucht habe...
Broken.
Super.
So.
Was haben wir...
Was haben wir als nächstes?
Ähm.
Lass mal.
Zum Beispiel...
Zum Beispiel das Amazon.
Amazon...
Ähm.
Ne.
Wie ist das?
Amazon New World...
MMO.
Existiert.
Gar nicht.
Gar nicht mal.
Okay.
Doch.
Hier.
Broken.
Excellent.
Warzone.
Äh.
Okay.
Warzone geht nicht.
Modern...
Modern Warfare.
Wo ist es denn?
2019?
Ach.
Das ist nicht auf Steam.
Sind das nur Sachen, die auf Steam sind?
Stimmt.
Wenn das ProtonDB ist, dann sind das nur Sachen, die ähm...
Steam sind.
Okay.
Das ergibt...
Das...
Das ergibt Sinn.
Ähm.
Okay.
Was ist auf Steam sonst noch rausgekommen?
Ähm.
Äh.
Dieses neue Warhammer-Dings?
Gedöns?
Wie das hieß?
Okay.
Also.
Gucken wir mal.
Ähm.
Auf.
Die Seiten sind ja schon wieder so benutzerfreundlich wie äh...
Manches Linux-Desktop.
Gucken wir mal.
Death Stranding könnten wir noch gucken.
Zum Beispiel.
Irgendwas Neues.
Ja.
Aber es hat eigentlich schon gereicht, dass äh.
Horizon Zero Dawn nicht läuft.
So.
Das erste, was mir eingefallen ist, was jetzt neu rauskommt, läuft nicht.
Das ist halt das Problem was du auch als 0815 äh...
Linux-User hast.
Dass es einfach nicht Next geht.
Da- und für dich komplett unerwartet kommt, dass es nicht geht.
Na?
Also wenn du im Vorfeld genau weißt, was du spielen willst, und will's nichts anderes
spielen.
Und du weißt, dass deine Spiele laufen.
Okay.
Gar kein Problem.
Aber einfach so 0815 drop in Replacement scores.
Klatschen.
Drop in Replacement ist es schlicht und ergreifend
nicht. Auch wenn das viele immer als
anders verkaufen wollen.
Wie sieht es mit
Overwatch aus? Overwatch läuft, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Wie läuft Overwatch?
Okay.
Installers unable to download Battle.net.
Also
100%ig gut für das Anhalt laufen.
Wenn man
keine Probleme mit hat, dass man
kleine, gerade wenn man
Competitive Multiplayer Sachen spielt,
unspielbar, okay.
Ja, was denn jetzt? Wir haben einmal Leute, die sagen,
es ist unspielbar und einmal Leute, die sagen, es läuft super.
So, was haben wir?
Iron Harvest
ist das jetzt irgendwie neue Strategie gedönst, ne?
Wie heißt das?
Iron Harvest.
Doch, es hieß so.
Gibt's nicht.
Dann suchen wir hier nochmal nach
Zero Dawn.
Okay, kein Problem.
Naja, gut.
Ja, ich will auch gar nicht
sagen, dass es irgendwie schlecht wäre oder dass
jemand total bescheuert ist, wenn er die Sachen auf Linux spielt.
Aber man kann sich da nicht drauf verlassen, dass das geht.
Vor allem, wenn du MMOs
spielst und Sachen mit Anti-Cheat,
da musst du ja quasi, also gerade
bei MMOs, da musst du ja bei jedem
Content-Patch dir erstmal denken, oh fuck,
läuft der Kram danach noch?
Das ist einfach nicht für den
normalen User, also immer noch nicht für den
normalen User geeignet. Das ist mittlerweile cool, was
alles geht.
Aber es ist kein
Drop-In-Replacement, wie sich das viele Leute
vorstellen. Ist es einfach nicht.
Sieht man ja daran. Das hat man jetzt ja wieder gesehen.
Das erste Game, nach was ich gesucht hab, ist
Max, mach mal den 16-Persönlichkeiten-Test.
Nee, warum?
Ja, okay.
War der hier verlinkt?
Ja, komm, schick Link. Ich mach den
Persönlichkeiten-Test.
16 Personalities.
Okay.
Was ist das?
Naja, anteilmäßig.
Muss man ja auch mal
sagen.
Hier
steht es jetzt auf 80%.
Sind was? Gold Plus? Nee, okay.
Machen wir mal Native. Native ist klar, da muss man
nicht drüber diskutieren, ob die laufen.
Also, wenn
50% der Games
Gold Plus laufen
und hier wahrscheinlich auch hauptsächlich
Games eingetragen werden,
die zumindest mal
starten, ich glaube,
da ist die Sache mit, dass...
im Anbetracht der Menge
der Games fast nichts läuft,
gar nicht mal so weit von der Realität
weg.
Es läuft zwar von den großen
Titeln das ein oder andere ganz brauchbar,
aber drauf verlassen, dass der Kram
funktioniert, kannst du dich nicht.
Guck mal, es sind 15.000 Games,
das ist ja nix.
Selbst wenn ich in Native spiele, das...
Wir müssen da noch gar nicht großartig
drüber diskutieren. Es ist schön, wenn du deine Sachen
da drauf spielen kannst, aber du kannst
dich einfach absolut nicht drauf verlassen und ich würde
im Traum nicht dran denken, und das sag ich, wie gesagt,
als jemand, der ziemlich
pro Linux ist und mit Linux auch sein Geld verdient,
ich würde im Traum nicht dran denken, das als meine Hauptplattform
zu verwenden, wenn eines meiner
Hauptanwendungszwecke
Spiele wären. Würde ich nicht machen.
Ja, wenn das die Games sind, die man spielt, wenn man
sagt, okay, ich spiele zum größten Teil CS und
Dota und sonst fast nichts, auch
von den Sachen, die neu rauskommen, fast nichts.
Okay, warum nicht? So, take the test.
Was? Slash.de. Was soll
das? Was? Okay.
Erhalte eine genaue
Beschreibung davon, wer du bist und warum du Dinge auf die
Art und Weise... Aha.
Warum schreibst du immer eine 1? Oh, das hab ich mal
erklärt. Guck mal, da haben wir sogar ein extra
Command für.
Okay, mache
den Test.
Du sollst weniger als 12 Minuten dafür brauchen. Beantworte die
Fragen ehrlich, auch wenn dir die Antworten nicht gefallen.
Weiß ich, ob das live
aufs Stream machen soll, ihr nachher was dafür fragen.
Komm. Okay, versuche
keine neutralen Antworten zu hinterlassen.
Okay.
Okay, ähm.
Ja, man kann die Musik mal
dudeln lassen.
Also, es fällt ihnen schwer, sich
anderen Menschen vorzustellen.
Was?
Es fällt mir schwer, sich andere... Hä?
Meinen die mit vorstellen, so
Hallo, ich bin der Max? Oder meinen die, es
fällt mir schwer, dass ich mir andere Menschen
vorstellen kann und das ist bloß
nicht richtig geschrieben.
Das Erste. Okay.
Ich mag andere Menschen
nicht. Also, ich...
Also, was ich überhaupt nicht...
Schwierig zu sagen. Was ich überhaupt
nicht mag, sind Vorstellungsrunden auf
irgendwelchen
Schulungen oder so. Letztens, wo ich
diese Microsoft Azure Schulung hatte, bin
ich irgendwie reingekommen, 5 Minuten zu spät,
weil es nicht funktioniert hat in Teams. Und auf einmal
höre ich, wir stellen uns jetzt einmal alle vor.
Fingersaug, Fingersaug, Fingersaug.
Also, ich würde sagen, mittlerweile geht's.
Früher habe ich
das extrem ungern gemacht,
weil ich mir da immer so Sachen aus den
Fingern saugen musste. Mittlerweile geht's
eigentlich.
So.
Sie verlieren sich oft so sehr in Gedanken,
dass sie ihre Umgebung ignorieren oder vergessen.
Ja.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Also, na gut, ich bin halt,
wenn ich was mache, gerade in Gedanken nicht,
weil wenn ich am Rechner sitze und irgendwie was
programmiere und mache, dann klar,
dann vergesse ich, was drumherum ist.
So. Sie versuchen, ihre
Mails möglichst zeitnah zu beibringen,
beantworten können, einen unordentlichen
Posteingang ist mir
vollkommen egal.
Und außerdem
ignoriere ich die meisten Mails, weil ich keinen Bock habe,
drauf zu antworten.
Jetzt auf der Arbeit vielleicht nicht, aber privat schon.
Ich kriege tatsächlich noch ab und zu Mails.
Es, ähm...
Ich meine, guckt euch meinen Desktop an.
Sieht das so aus, als hätte ich irgendwie
ein Problem mit einem unordentlichen Posteingang?
So.
Ähm. Es fällt,
ihnen leicht, entspannt und fokussiert zu bleiben,
selbst wenn sie ein wenig unter Druck stehen.
Ja.
Also,
ein wenig mag ich eigentlich sogar.
Das ist ein bisschen,
es ist ein bisschen so wie, ähm,
so ein bisschen wie im Stream.
Wenn man, wenn man im Livestream ist
und einem die Leute zugucken,
kann man nicht so entspannt
denken, wie wenn man,
ähm,
wie wenn man jetzt quasi allein vom Rechner ist.
Aber, ich muss ehrlich sagen,
so ein bisschen Anspannung mag ich eigentlich
ganz gern, weil es mir dabei hilft,
nicht so sidetracked zu werden.
Und ihr kennt mich im Stream, ich mach schon auch
öfters mal den komplexen, also,
Dinger, die damit überhaupt nichts zu tun haben.
Jetzt könnt ihr euch überlegen, wie, wie
effizient ich manchmal Sachen mach, ja.
Also.
Ich mag, ich find das eigentlich ganz gut.
So ein bisschen, ein bisschen Anspannung, ja.
Viel ist für eine Art,
aber ein bisschen find ich ganz gut.
Normalerweise beginnen sie keine
Gespräche, ähm,
ja.
Die tun selten etwas, nur aus
purer Neugier.
Kommt, kommt auf den
Bereich an, ja.
Ähm,
also die meisten Sachen, auch hier,
dieses ganze Microcontroller-Programmierzeug
mach mach ich nur, weil ich neugierig drauf bin,
nicht, weil es da irgendwas bringt.
Ähm, ich bin,
also ich bin halt meistens auf die Sachen neugierig,
die mich auch interessieren und dann mach ich
sie auch. Was ich jetzt nicht machen würde,
ist, äh, ich geh mal ne Runde klettern
oder so. Was soll ich da drauf sagen?
Die tun selten etwas, nur aus
purer Neugier.
Keine Ahnung.
So.
Sie fühlen sich anderen Menschen überlegen.
Hä, das ist okay. Das ist,
das ist ne fiese Frage.
Also ich bin, ich bin der festen Überzeugung,
dass 90% der Leute,
ähm, in, in dem, was sie
machen, schlecht sind.
Das heißt nicht, dass ich unbedingt
das besser könnte.
Aber ich, ich, ich glaube zumindest,
dass die Sachen,
von denen ich glaube,
dass ich sie kann, dass ich die auch
wirklich ganz gut kann.
Im Vergleich zu dem 0,15
Durchschnitt, äh, Lowbob.
Dafür weiß ich aber auch,
dass es genug Sachen gibt, von denen ich
absolut keinen Plan hab.
Ja, so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen schon,
ja. Aber nur in manchen Bereichen.
Ich weiß halt in vielen Bereichen, dass ich kacke bin.
Und da, da halt nicht.
Organisiert zu sein, ist Ihnen wichtiger,
als anpassungsfähig zu sein.
Vorbereitung ist wichtig, ja.
Aber mit organisiert, also Ordnung
mein ich damit nicht, ja.
Vorbereitet sein ist wichtig.
Also vorbereitet sein ist wichtig.
Ja, also zum Beispiel, wenn ich weiß,
sagen wir mal, morgen kommt irgendwie
irgendein Vorstandstyp zum, zum
besichtigen, oder so.
Dann überlege ich mir im Vor-, Vorgehensweise,
Vorfeld schon. Okay, was
für eine möglichst diplomatische,
unverfängliche Antwort auf irgendeine
Smalltalk-Frage kannst du dem geben?
Du musst das wörtlich nehmen. Naja,
organisiert in Form von ordentlich, dann
boah, keine Ahnung. Das ist
echt scheiße.
Weißt du, was ich dazu sagen soll? Organisiert zu sein
ist... Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Kein Schimmer.
Sie sind für gewöhnlich...
Nein.
Hochmotiviert bin ich
selten. Es ist ihnen
wichtiger, dass niemand verärgert wird, als
dass sie eine Debatte... Das ist tatsächlich so.
Also ich versuche die meisten
Sachen wirklich
so diplomatisch
wie es geht zu handhaben.
Und mir ist es lieber,
ich hab am Ende zwar
vielleicht recht aus meiner Sicht,
also ich weiß, dass ich recht habe,
oder dass der andere, was auch immer,
aber mir ist es lieber, ich lass dann
sogar dem anderen das letzte Wort,
dass
beide Seiten irgendwie den Eindruck haben,
okay, das hat sich gelohnt. Ja, doch, tatsächlich.
Sie haben oft das
Gefühl, dass sie sich gegenüber anderen
rechtfertigen müssen.
Ja, ich erkläre ganz gern, warum ich
Sachen mache. Vor allem bei
Sachen, wo ich denke,
dass sie eben...
dass man erstmal gar nicht versteht, warum
ich sie so gemacht habe. Aber es hat ja seinen
Grund. Ja, ja, stimmt schon.
Stimmt schon.
Ihre Umgebung daheim und am Arbeitsplatz
ist...
ist ziemlich ordentlich, nein.
So ordentlich, wie notwendig.
Ich hab mein Werkzeug letztens
in ein paar Schränke sortiert, aber das war's dann auch.
Es macht Ihnen nichts aus,
im Mittelpunkt der Aufmerksamkeit zu stehen.
Äh, das stimmt tatsächlich. Also,
ich hab nichts dagegen,
wenn das, wenn irgendwie einer was toll
findet, was ich gemacht hab, das ist in Ordnung, ja.
Okay.
Sie halten sich eher für praktisch veranlagt als
kreativ. Beides.
Also, ich glaube, in manchen
Bereichen, also gerade,
gerade wenn man Problemlösungen
und sowas, glaube ich schon, dass ich da recht kreativ
bin, aber ich interessiere mich auch
für, äh, so Maker-Kram.
Also, pff, schwierig. Also, ich würde auch
sagen, so eher in der Mitte, ja.
Ich bastel gerne, aber ich, ich brauche
kein... Also, es ist schwierig.
Äh, andere
schaffen es selten, sie zu verärgern.
Also, ja,
das stimmt,
aber wenn mich jemand ärgert,
dann ärgert mich das richtig.
Ja, genau. Zum Beispiel,
die Bahn regt mich öfters auf, aber wenn
die mich aufregt, dann so.
Ne, ich reg mich schon, ich, ich reg mich schon
öfters mal auf, ja.
Er ist aber so, in Anbetracht der Menge, was
mich aufregen könnte,
glaube ich, rege ich mich in letzter Zeit doch nicht mehr,
aber insgesamt regt mich doch schon einiges, ja doch.
Ähm, ihre Reisepläne
sind normalerweise gut durchgedacht, ja.
Ähm, es fällt ihnen
oft schwer, die Gefühle von anderen
nachzuempfinden.
Nö, ich kann mir das eigentlich meistens
ganz gut vorstellen, was bei anderen Leuten
los ist.
Ihre Stimmung kann sich sehr schnell ändern.
Nö.
So, ähm, weil es sollten die
Wahrheit wichtiger sein, als die
als die wunden Punkte anderer.
Ja.
Sie sorgen sich selten,
wie sich ihre Taten auf andere auswirken.
Ja.
Also, wenn man jetzt, also, wie gesagt,
ich, ich, das passt tatsächlich,
ähm, wenn ich mit anderen über Sachen
diskutiere, dann, dann möchte ich, dass
beide Seiten, also, dass keine der Seiten irgendwie
am Ende das Gefühl hat, man sind die
anderen Spasten oder umgedreht irgendwie,
äh, mit dem rede ich nie wieder oder sowas.
Das nicht. Aber ansonsten,
so, alle anderen Sachen
ist mir erstmal das Wichtigste,
dass es den Leuten,
also mir und den Leuten, die mir wichtig
sind, für die
was Vorteilhaftes ist.
Und wenn es dann irgendwie auf
Person XY, zu dem ich keinen Bezug
habe und die mir am Arsch vorbeigeht, vielleicht negative
Auswirkungen hat, ist mir
das, äh, ziemlich egal.
So, ähm,
ihre Arbeitsweise ähnelt eher
willkürlichen Energieschümen als
einem methodischen Orga...
Ja, ja,
vielleicht eher, ja. Sie sind
oft neidisch auf andere.
Oft neidisch auf andere?
Bisschen vielleicht, aber oft,
na, oft nicht. Also,
manche Sachen gehen mir auf den Keks. Also,
ich, ich seh, sag mal, neidisch
eher nicht. Ich seh halt viel Ungerechtigkeiten,
die wir haben, die ich
nicht gut finde. Aber das ist ja, hat ja mit neidisch
nix zu tun. Nö, eigentlich nicht.
Ähm, ein interessantes Buch oder
ein Videospiel ist oft besser als eine Pa... Ah, ja,
unbedingt. Äh, Buch weniger,
aber Spiel. Also, bevor ich mich auf ne Party gehe,
da spiel ich lieber zum 20. Half-Life durch.
Die Fähigkeit, einen Plan
zu entwickeln und dabei zu bleiben, ist der wichtigste
Teil von jedem Projekt.
Wenn's denn... Naja.
Einen Plan zu entwickeln,
ja, man sollte den Plan haben,
was stimmt nicht, musst du ankreuzen?
Was denn? Bei was?
Ja, dann so rum,
meinetwegen. Äh, ja, wahrscheinlich.
So. Die Fähigkeit...
Also, nen Plan zu entwickeln, äh,
da fehlen ja die meisten schon, einen ordentlichen Plan
zu entwickeln. Dabei zu bleiben,
nicht. Also, man sollte schon ne gute
Vorstellung von, haben von dem, was man machen will
und was eigentlich die Ziele sind und, äh, wie, was
man... Wenn sich allerdings rausstellt,
dass man irgendwas
total, äh, verkackt hat, dann,
äh, aber ein Plan ist schon wichtig.
Ja. Sie verlieren sich selten
in Tagträumerei und Gedanken.
Ich bin, wenn ich was, wenn ich was mache, mach ich das
fokussiert, aber ansonsten, äh,
sitz ich selten rum und denke
darüber nach, ob jetzt irgendwie,
äh, grün,
wirklich grün ist, ja.
Natur! Ha! Lull!
Welche Natur?
Wenn jemand nicht schnell auf ihre E-Mails antwortet,
machen sie sich Sorgen.
Äh, nein. Ähm,
als Elternteil wäre es Ihnen wichtiger,
dass ihr Kind freundlich wird als intelligent.
Nö.
Big Brain.
Beste.
Huge IQ.
Was sie erlauben, anderen Menschen nicht
ihre Taten zu beeinflussen. Wie soll das überhaupt
funktionieren?
Du kannst andere Leute nicht davon,
du kannst andere Leute nicht davon
abhalten, äh, irgendwie
Einfluss auf dich zu nehmen oder irgendwas zu machen,
was dich, äh, dir in den Weg kommt.
Ach so, nee, die meinen,
ob ich quasi auf andere höre,
äh,
weniger,
weniger, also,
ich hab, also, die Sache ist die,
wenn ich Sachen mache,
dann sind die oftmals aus meiner Sicht
ziemlich detailliert
durchdacht.
Und wenn dann Leute kommen
und sagen was dazu,
dann passt das oftmals nicht zu meinen Vorstellungen.
Deswegen
höre ich mir das vielleicht an,
aber mach's dann nicht.
Weil ich meinen Plan für
sinnvoller halte, weil ich im Vorfeld schon
mir überlegt hab.
Ihre Träume konzentrieren sich mehr auf die reale
Welt und deren, äh,
Ereignisse.
Meine Träume?
Meinen die jetzt, was ich mir wünsche?
Oder meinen die, was ich wirklich, also, die meinen das,
was ich nachts träume? Okay.
Ich hab letztens was von Keck W.
geträumt.
Ich weiß nicht mehr was, ich kann mich
nur noch an das E-Mode erinnern.
Ich hab letztens irgendwas, Keck, da,
Video geträumt.
Achso, sie erlauben anderen Menschen
nicht ihre Taten zu beeinflussen. Ah ja.
Okay, ja.
Ja, ist der Twitch-Chat real?
Chat.
Ist der Twitch-Chat real?
Das ist schwierig zu beantworten.
Ihre Träume
konzentrieren sich mehr auf die reale.
Kann ich so als nix zu sagen.
An einem neuen Arbeitsplatz
machen sie sich schnell bei Gesellschaft...
Nein.
Nein, auf gar keinen Fall.
Sie improvisieren lieber als sorgsam
zu planen. Nein.
Ihre Emotionen steuern sie
mehr als, dass sie diese
steuern.
Niemals schneller gewählt.
Weiß ich nicht. Boah,
keine Ahnung. Ja, echt.
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Muss ich weiter machen.
Ob du emotional... Ich kann das echt schlecht
einschätzen gerade.
Vielleicht, weil ich das
schlecht einschätzen kann, ist sogar
vielleicht eher, eher
das hier? Ich weiß nicht.
Sie gehen gern
zu gesellschaftlichen Veranstaltungen, bei denen man
sich nicht... Bei denen man sich verkleidet?
Nein. Gehst du weg?
Ich geh gern... Nein.
Gesellschaftliche
Veranstaltungen.
So Fasching oder sowas ist das. Ja,
Verkleid... Okay, Rollenspiele.
Sie verbringen häufiger Zeit damit,
unrealistische und unpraktische Ideen zu überdenken,
die jedoch faszinieren. Das stimmt, ja.
Ja, das stimmt.
Viele Sachen...
Also, auch viele Projekte
und so, die sind nicht unbedingt so sinnvoll,
aber die sind interessant. Das stimmt, ja.
Ich hab auch schon viele, viele Sachen
mir hier angeguckt, einfach weil ich sie recht spannend...
Nee, nee, recht spannend finde,
ohne dass ich... Wo ich weiß, dass da nie was
Sinnvolles bei rumkommt.
Nein, das stimmt nicht. Plan, Plan ist...
Plan ist...
Ja, wobei...
Ich weiß, das klingt merkwürdig und
das passt überhaupt nicht. Auf der einen Seite hab ich gesagt,
bei mir ist die Sache unordentlich,
unordentlich und nicht organisiert, aber ich hab...
Bevor ich Sachen mache, wenn ich denn
Sachen mache, ja, hab ich gerne
einen Plan, weil ich will, dass ich
möglichst schnell und effektiv damit
fertig bin, dass ich mich wieder
anderen Sachen widmen kann, ja.
Deswegen sag ich ja, dass
faule Leute die besten, die besten
Ergebnisse haben. Weil sie, weil
sie versuchen, die Sachen möglichst effektiv
und möglichst so zu machen, dass sie sich
danach nicht mehr beschäftigen müssen.
Okay, weiter.
Ja, ja,
tatsächlich.
Tatsächlich, ich will eigentlich eher
meine Ruhe,
außer mit Leuten, die ich, außer Leute, die ich mag,
ja. Also den Twitch-Chat,
der Twitch-Chat ist natürlich, den Twitch-Chat mag ich,
ja. Wo haben wir den passenden?
Wenn sie ein Unternehmen hätten,
würde es ihnen schwer fallen, loyale
Mitarbeiter zu entlassen, die allerdings geringe...
Tja.
Ich weiß, dass ich so ein bisschen, dass ich,
ich bin da ziemlich, ziemlich...
Das ist...
Manchmal hab ich das Gefühl, ich bin nicht, ich bin,
ich bin gestört, ja. Weil,
auf der einen Seite, ja,
also, auf der einen Seite denke ich, ja,
also, zu Leuten, die ich einen
persönlichen Bezug habe und
die da zuhalten und so, die würde ich
ungern entlassen. Auf der anderen Seite
fucken mich Leute übelst ab, die nix machen.
Genau, genau. So geht's mir nämlich auch.
Wir hatten beispielsweise auf der Arbeit einen,
der war extrem nett.
Der hat auch immer, also bei uns im Team,
der hat auch immer, äh, äh,
Süßkram verteilt
und hat auf Meetings mitgebracht, so.
Also, ich mochte den Kerl wirklich.
So. Und auf der einen Seite
finde ich's wirklich schade, dass der weg ist.
Aber auf der anderen Seite
muss ich sagen, ähm,
er hat halt wenig gemacht.
Ich find's wirklich schade, dass der weg ist.
Also, ich, ich mag den wirklich, aber
auf der anderen Seite hat er mich öfters mal
extrem genervt, ähm,
weil er Sachen einfach nicht gemacht hat.
Ja, so...
Ich, ich, ich kann's halt nicht ab
auf Dauer, wenn die Leute
nach fünf Mal sagen, die Sachen
immer noch nicht machen.
Sie machen sich oft Gedanken über den Grund der menschlichen Existenz...
Über das große Ganze mach ich mir schon Gedanken, ja.
Logik ist normalerweise wichtiger als Herz, Bauchgefühl, wichtige Entscheidungen...
Ja, ja, tatsächlich.
Ähm, auch, auch wenn's einen manchmal,
auch wenn's einen manchmal überkommt,
auch wenn's einen manchmal überkommt, aber, ähm,
wenn man mal sich dann einen Tag drüber Gedanken gemacht hat,
kommt man oftmals zu ganz un...
zu ganz anderen Entscheidungen.
Also, ich weiß, dass Logik wichtiger ist,
auch wenn ich manchmal mich selbst nicht dran halte, aber wer macht das schon, ja.
Ihnen ist es wichtiger, flexibel zu bleiben, als Aufgabenliste zu arbeiten.
Kommt drauf, kommt drauf an, was auf den Listen draufsteht.
Wenn Ihr Freund, Ihre Freundin, was...
Mädchen, was ist, was...
Die Frage, die kann ich nicht beantworten.
Ähm, wenn, wenn Ihre Freundin, Ihre Freundin über etwas traurig ist,
dann bieten Sie wahrscheinlich eher emotional Unterstützung an,
als dass Sie die Möglichkeiten zur Problemlösung vorschlagen.
Ähm...
Oh, das kann ich schlecht einschätzen.
Ganz ehrlich?
Warum nicht beides?
Also, ehrlich gesagt,
versuche ich meistens, irgendwie, halbwegs zu verstehen, also,
wenn ich mich mal doch mal mit Emotionen anderer Leute da auseinandersetze,
und das müssen ja Leute sein, die ich mag,
ähm,
dann versuche ich mich schon reinzuversetzen, wie die...
was das Problem ist,
aber ich versuche dann auch meistens auf irgendwie
sinnvolle Lösungen zu kommen.
Ja, kann ich nichts sagen.
Äh, Sie fühlen sich selten unsicher.
Kommt drauf an.
Oh, das ist scheiße zu beantworten, weil...
Weil...
Wenn das was ist, wo ich weiß, dass ich mich auskenne,
dann ja.
Wenn das was ist, wo ich weiß, dass ich keine Ahnung hab,
dann schon.
Ich, ich, ich tendiere...
Ich tendiere eher zu nein,
weil ich weiß, dass es deutlich mehr Sachen gibt, wo ich planlos bin,
als Sachen, wo ich mich auskenne.
Äh, Sie haben keine Probleme damit, einen persönlichen Zeitplan festzulegen.
Haha, lol.
Ich mache nur das Wichtigste in, in, zur Deadliner.
Also auch, also, komplett real life.
So eine Steuererklärung wird immer am 30. Dezember abgegeben, so, nach dem Ausdruck.
Recht zu haben ist bei der Teamarbeit wichtiger als kooperativ zu sein.
Das Problem bei Teamarbeit ist, wenn man,
mal angenommen, man ist wirklich davon überzeugt, Recht zu haben,
und man macht nur die Sachen, um sie dem anderen Recht zu machen, ist auch doof.
Auf der anderen Seite mag ich es nicht, wenn man, ähm,
Sachen durchdrückt und alle, an, und alle, und alle Scheiße finden.
Das ist, ist auch schwierig zu sagen.
Äh, Sie sind der Ansicht, dass alle Meinungen respektiert werden sollen und nicht,
und zwar unabhängig davon, ob diese von Fakten unterstützt werden oder nicht.
Ähm, ja, tatsächlich, ähm, wenn einer seine Meinung sagt, soll er das machen?
Ich, ich, ich werde sie wahrscheinlich, wenn sie nicht gut begründet ist, ziemlich bescheuert finden.
Aber, äh, der, der darf ruhig seine Meinung sagen.
Das ist okay.
Ich finde es zwar total beknackt, wahrscheinlich, was er sagt,
wenn, wenn, na, also wenn mir da jetzt zum Beispiel einer ankommt mit flacher Erde oder sonst was,
da bin ich schon dafür, dass der sich öffentlich äußern darf dazu, dass der das, äh, so sieht,
und der sollte da auch keine Probleme durchbekommen, aber ich finde es bescheuert.
Machen wir mal so, vielleicht nicht ganz so.
Kokona, genau.
Sie haben mehr Energie, nachdem sie Zeit mit einer Gruppe von Leuten verbracht haben.
Nee, eigentlich bin ich danach müde.
Anstrengend.
Andere Leute.
Sie verlegen Re-
Haha, ja.
Das stimmt.
Respektieren und sich äußern sind unterschiedliche Sachen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Naja, damit, das, das, die meinen damit schon, dass man, äh, ihn jetzt nicht irgendwie dafür direkt schlecht, äh, schlecht machen müsste.
Das ist schwierig.
Keine Ahnung.
Alter.
Klar, wir sind ja gleich fertig.
Sie stufen sich selbst als emotional sehr stabil ein.
Ey, das, ja, normalerweise schon.
Das liegt aber daran, weil mir die meisten, meisten Sachen auf der Welt komplett am Arsch vorbeigehen.
Sachen, die mich persönlich betreffen, wie zum Beispiel, als meine Katze gestorben ist, das nicht.
Also, mir gehen halt 99% der Welt am Arsch vorbei mittlerweile.
Deswegen, ja, deswegen juckt mich das überhaupt nicht.
Ihr Kopf ist stets voll, ist stets voller unerforschte Ideen.
Äh, das ist richtig.
Zwar sehr spezifische Ideen.
Jetzt nicht sonderlich, nicht sonderlich breit gefächert, ja.
Also, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich sage, ah, ich könnte mal nach Afrika fahren oder so.
Aber ich habe 20.000 Projekte, auch teilweise unvollendet.
Ihr guckt euch mein GitHub-Repo an.
Ähm, sie würden sich selbst nicht als Traum...
Also, ich, ich mache die meisten Sachen schon mit Realitätsbezug.
Guck, dass das irgendwas ist, was man realistisch machen kann.
Weil Sachen, die, ähm, komplett unrealistisch umzusetzen sind, vielleicht ist es manchmal besser, man macht von den tausend Sachen, die man im Kopf hat, ein paar.
Macht von den tausend Sachen, die man im Kopf hat, Sachen, die, wenn man wirklich dann was macht, äh, die man auch, äh, verwirklichen kann, ja.
Es fällt ihnen gewöhnlich schwer, sich zu entspannen, wenn sie von vielen, wenn sie vor vielen Menschen sprechen.
Ich muss sagen, ehrlich gesagt, das ist viel besser geworden.
Aber ne, Moment.
Das ist viel besser geworden.
Ich habe früher, gerade in der Schule, ich habe absolut, weil es auch irgendwie nicht zu mir passt, ja.
Ähm, auch zu den anderen Sachen.
Ähm, ich habe es absolut nicht gemocht, irgendwelche Präsentationen zu halten.
Bis ich irgendwann festgestellt habe, dass mir das Spaß macht.
Und, ähm, warum ich das immer schlecht fand, lag daran, weil es eigentlich so meiner...
Eigentlich widerspricht das so meiner Natur mit großen Menschenansammlungen.
So.
Deswegen mochte ich das nie ursprünglich.
So auch nicht.
Aus, so innerer Bauchgefühl mäßig.
Präsentationen zu halten.
Aber, auf der anderen Seite mag ich das, wenn andere Leute das geil finden, was ich sage.
So.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen, äh, Konflikt.
Und deswegen habe ich mich früher auch, wir reden jetzt hier so Schule, Schule mäßig.
Weil ich es auch, so von meiner inneren Einstellung her nicht mochte, mit vielen Leuten.
Hab ich immer...
Mich nicht richtig auf die Präsentation vorbereitet.
Und dementsprechend liefen die dann auch scheiße.
Aber irgendwann habe ich mal gemerkt, dass das eigentlich eine richtig coole Sache ist.
Also, ich erzähle eigentlich gerne Sachen mit, von denen ich mich auskenne.
Stell dir vor, du würdest jetzt vor 250 Leuten echt labern.
Na ja gut, da würde ich vielleicht nicht Poggers, Poggers und, äh, KekW und sowas sagen.
Aber, äh, ich habe mich ja mittlerweile sogar schon auf der Arbeit freiwillig zu Sachen gemeldet, wo man am Ende was präsentieren muss.
Und jetzt nicht irgendwie einfach nur vor, vor drei Leuten.
Sondern, äh, erstens von, von bis zuvorstand.
Und dann auch den ganzen Tag über, äh, immer wieder vor Krüppchen aus 20 Leuten.
Also, mittlerweile macht mir das tatsächlich Spaß.
Ja.
Und das liegt daran, weil ich festgestellt habe, wenn man gut vorbereitet ist auf so eine Präsentation.
Und gut vorbereitet sein heißt halt auch, man muss das vorher ein paar Mal, ein paar Mal geübt haben.
Also sprich, ähm, ich bin niemals, ich, ich komme mit, ich komme mit Notizen nicht klar.
Ja.
Also ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht dastehen bei einer Präsentation und, äh, mich von meinen Notizen irgendwie leiten lassen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Ich, ich brauche genaue Vorstellungen davon, ähm, was ich zu, bei welchem Bild und so, was ich da, äh.
Ähm, also nicht, nichts Einstudiertes.
Sondern einfach, dass wenn ich quasi dann, sag mal, irgendwie eine Seite weitermache.
Dann, ähm, dann habe ich genau im Kopf, ah ja, stimmt.
Das ist die Seite, wo es das und das zu erzählen gibt, ohne Notizen.
Deswegen mache ich so eine Präsentation meistens.
Das, also ich, ich schaue, dass man meistens schon 1, 2 Wochen vorher soweit fertig ist.
Und dann mache ich die immer noch mit ein paar Leuten zusammen.
Äh, im Vorfeld ein paar Mal.
Und da merkt man auch, dass man sich immer mehr so Standardsprüche zurückzieht.
Zu den passenden, zu den passenden Folien, zu den passenden Ereignissen merkt.
Und auch zu den passenden Fragen, die von den Leuten kommen.
Da hat man dann so ein paar, so ein paar Standardsprüche schon davor.
Ja.
Einer meiner Lieblings, meiner Lieblingsredewendung ist.
Und was man auch nicht vergessen darf.
Das sage ich immer.
Immer, wenn ich keine Ahnung habe.
Was ich jetzt konkret darauf sage.
Dann sage ich, ah ja, das ist gut.
Aber was man auch nicht vergessen darf, ist das und das.
Ich weiß, ich weiß nicht, ob euch das schon mal aufgefallen ist.
Das sage ich echt gerne.
Was man auch nicht vergessen darf.
Was man auch nicht vergessen darf, ist folgendes.
So, ähm.
Also mittlerweile mache ich das tatsächlich.
Mache ich das wirklich, mache ich das echt gern.
Ja.
Irgendwelche Sachen präsentieren und vorstellen.
Ich würde sogar fast sagen.
Mittlerweile macht mir das richtig Spaß.
Und mir macht das, mir macht das sogar mittlerweile so viel Spaß.
Dass ich sogar, dass ich sogar anfange.
Mich auf Sachen zu konzentrieren.
Und das ist ja eigentlich was, was nicht so typisch ist bei mir.
Die nicht, ähm.
Die nicht rein inhaltlich sind.
Sondern mir auch sogar überlege.
So Sachen wie, was für eine Geste könnte man jetzt machen.
Oder, oder, ähm.
Auf welcher Seite vom, vom, vom Fernseher.
Wenn du, wenn du ein Fernseher hast.
Oder vom, vom, vom Anzeigerät.
Stelle ich mich jetzt bei dieser Sache.
Also ich versuche jetzt sogar mittlerweile schon die Sache nicht nur inhaltlich gut rüber zu bringen.
Sondern, dass das auch noch einen, noch einen guten Gesamteindruck macht.
So dass ich.
Mein Ziel ist eigentlich, dass die Leute sich das Ganze inhaltlich.
Dass sie das inhaltlich gefällt.
Und, dass sie von Anfang an, äh.
Interessiert sind und sich nicht langweilen.
Ja, gut.
Also mittlerweile macht mir das wirklich Spaß.
So, im Allgemeinen verlasse sie sich eher auf ihre Erfahrung als auf ihre Vor-.
Ja.
Also wenn ich Sachen mache, dann äh.
Am liebsten, wo ich mich auskenne.
Äh.
Sie sorgen sich zu viel, was andere Leute denken.
Ja, ich sag ja immer, dass man das nicht machen sollte.
Ja.
Aber ich muss sagen.
Ich mache es immer noch zu viel.
Alter.
Fertig.
Ne.
Wie?
Nicht fertig?
Alter, wie lange dauert das?
Zwölf Minuten?
So, in einem vollen Raum bleiben sie näher an der Wand und meinen die Raum-Mitte.
Ja, aber das ist normal.
Das ist normal.
Also, die meisten Leute, wenn ihnen unbekannt.
Angenommen, man geht in ein Restaurant, wo man noch nicht gewesen ist.
Man setzt sich immer an die Wand gegenüber von der Tür.
Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das schon mal aufgefallen ist.
Wenn ihr irgendwo reingeht, wo ihr neu seid.
Ihr setzt euch mit dem Rücken an die Wand, mit dem Blick zur Tür.
Das ist ganz normal.
Was?
Wenn man ultra-extrovertiert ist, setzt man sich in die Mitte.
Echt?
Ernsthaft?
Sie neigen dazu.
Sie neigen dazu, Dinge aufzuschieben, bis nicht mehr.
Ja.
Naja.
Ne.
Also.
Ja.
Ich schiebe gerne Dinge auf.
Ja, ja.
Das stimmt.
Also.
Aber die meisten, die wichtigsten Sachen kriege ich fertig.
Sie sind sehr nervös in stressigen Situationen.
Es kommt.
Ey, das kann ich nicht sagen.
Eigentlich nicht.
Es kommt halt auf die Situation an.
Also in stressigen Situationen selbst.
Nein.
Da kann ich mich auch immer zusammenreißen und nachzudenken.
In sehr stressigen Situationen ja.
Also in sehr stressigen Situationen ist quasi.
Nee, bei dir ist jetzt irgendwie die Rakete eingeschlagen.
Dann.
Ich.
Machen wir mal so.
Heide.
Ach du weißt.
Jetzt muss ich mal gucken, dass es richtig aussieht.
Heide.
Kloba.
Lelite.
Zwei Monate.
Dankeschön.
Für den Zap.
Okay.
Sie glauben, dass es lohnenswerter ist, von anderen gemocht zu werden, als einflussreich
zu sein.
Boah.
Das ist.
Das ist schwierig.
Ich meine, du kannst dir zwar nichts kaufen davon, wenn dich andere mögen.
Aber gerade auf YouTube ist es nun mal so, dass das da.
Also das.
Das da.
Und das da.
Äh.
Ziemlich Hand in Hand gehen.
Ja.
Also sprich.
Du musst auf YouTube mehr oder weniger gemocht werden, dass du einflussreich wirst.
Aber insgesamt.
Boah.
Keine Ahnung.
Fällt mir jetzt nichts zu ein.
Nee.
Ganz ehrlich.
Also wenn ich.
Wenn ich jetzt mal so rein bauchgefühlmäßig sagen würde.
Würde ich sagen.
Ähm.
Also von anderen gemocht werden, finde ich.
Ist.
Ist nicht.
Ja.
Da stehe ich wohl nur beansprucht, aber dann sage ich.
Man hat ein.
Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob man sagen kann, erfüllteres Leben.
Wenn man nicht.
Also, sag.
Sag mal so wenn man.
India vielleicht.
Wenn man ein bisschen Kohle hat oder s UNDS WAS?
Sag mal so, wenn man, wenn man ein bisschen Kohle hat oder sonst was, wenn man da auch
andere dran teilhaben lässt, wenn man zum Beispiel etwas an das Tierheim spendet oder
sonst was.
Also ansonsten.
Aber auf die Sache.
Ich kann es echt schlecht beantworten.
Sie haben sich schon immer für unkonventionelle und mehr deutliche Dinge interessiert.
Stimmt.
In gesellschaftlichen Situation, Situation campo.
ergreifen sie oft die initiative nein mache ich nicht nur wenn es mir zu sehr auf den sack geht
die frage ist er bist du netter arbeitskollege oder der boss dann bin ich versuche das meistens
gut auszukommen also ja das stimmt wenn man das so sieht wenn man das so sieht dann ist das so
weil ich habe keinerlei karriereambitionen ich drücke mich da immer um sachen ja ich
hatte letztens einen termin mit einem was was war der irgendwas das zweithöchste auf unserem
organikram hatte ich letzte wochen termin weil er gesagt hat er ist er ist neu und möchte ein
paar sachen wissen und so weiß ich wieder da überhaupt auf mich gekommen ist mich da jetzt
einzuladen es mir wieder eingefallen dass so eine management hierarchie ebene definitiv nichts für
mich wäre also ich ergreife gern die initiative wenn es mir gerne
gar zu dumm wird also wenn leute seit 30 minuten versuchen etwas zu diskutieren und und nur
scheiße bei rauskommt dann ja ansonsten gehen wir gesellschaftlichen situationen komplett am
arsch vorbei und ich halte mich raus so lange es mich nicht betrifft ok ok ergebnis ergebnis
ja das stimmt das stimmt virtuose aha virtuose ist pa
war
was auch immer das ist ok da ist sogar die erklärung drunter ok virtuose ok virtuose
lieben es mit ihren händen und ihren augen zu voll indem sie die welt um sich herum mit kühlem
verstand und geistiger neugierige berühren und untersuchen menschen mit diesem persönlichkeits
typ sind natürliche tatmenschen ich weiß ja nicht die ein projekt nach dem ich weiß ja nicht wie
was zum nein das stimmt überhaupt nicht ok alles klar jetzt weiß ich über mich bescheid super virtuose
der große philosoph was für zeug aber kennt das überhaupt noch jemand gandalf sachs kann
sachs geil
was
oh mann
oh mann es gibt es so viele geile so kleine filmchen zu
es gibt es so viele geile so kleine filmchen zu
es gibt es so viele geile so kleine filmchen zu herr der ringe wo sie irgendwas verarschen
herr der ringe wo sie irgendwas verarschen
herr der ringe wo sie irgendwas verarschen sie sind teilweise übelst lustig
sie sind teilweise übelst lustig
sie sind teilweise übelst lustig ok was kann man cooles track ever ok ok ich
ok was kann man cooles track ever ok ok ich
ok was kann man cooles track ever ok ok ich guck mir gerne hardware von anderen
guck mir gerne hardware von anderen
guck mir gerne hardware von anderen leuten an dass ich ein bisschen drüber
leuten an dass ich ein bisschen drüber
leuten an dass ich ein bisschen drüber ablästern kann
Ach Moment, Airconditioning, ja das ist ja langweilig.
Das ist ja, Moment, der baut eine Klimaanlage in sein Rack ein, das ist ja, das ist ja langweilig.
Das kann ja jeder.
Es macht nur nicht jeder, weil es eigentlich meistens überhaupt nicht notwendig ist.
Der will es aber daheim echt wissen, ne?
Der will es daheim wirklich wissen.
Wie gesagt, also, mein Rack sieht ja mittlerweile immer noch mehr oder weniger so aus wie hier im Video.
Wenn die Tür zu ist, hier ist keine Klimaanlage drin und auch im Sommer ist es hier relativ warm drin.
Aber kühl genug, dass es der Hardware nichts ausmacht.
Ich, Rack, ich will jetzt ein bisschen lästern über Hardware, nicht,
Homeserver, ich will jetzt ein bisschen lästern über Hardware von anderen Leuten.
Was hat er hier?
Ah!
Gute Bosch-Aggoschrauber.
Der baut einen Rack.
Tour of my Home Network, jawohl, zeig's her.
Was auch immer.
Wo geht's los?
Das sieht ja aus wie 1995 von der Kameraqualität 4 zu 3, ist es wahrscheinlich auch.
Wow, wow, wow.
Son.
Paints Champ.
Aber gut, das ist von 1995 oder so.
At one point I had a CD-ROM-Tower with 7 CD-ROM-Drives in it and one of those was a burner
and that was primarily where I stored most of my files at the time.
But, as you can imagine, with trying to store more and more digital videos...
2001, ja, so sieht's aus.
In fact, as optical media continued to get cheaper, I also had come to the conclusion...
Okay, wo geht's los?
...that CD and especially DVD recordables were...
Hey Max, hast du WOTS auf Twitch?
Wo du etwas mit dem Raspberry Pi gemacht hattest?
Äh, ja, wir haben alle WOTS im Archiv und ich hab auch sehr viele WOTS mit dem Raspberry Pi,
aber das... da musst du mal durchgucken.
Also, ja, sau viele.
Wir haben bestimmt, keine Ahnung, schon 100 Streams gemacht mit dem Raspberry Pi in Verbindung.
Also, jetzt zeigt das hier.
Jede Menge Netgear-Dinger.
Kann man die Auflösung noch ein bisschen hoch machen?
Nee.
Okay, warte, erst mal hier unten hatten wir die schönen Kokona-Steckdosen.
Das ist so... wobei, ist das die Kokona... das ist gar nicht die Kokona-Steckdose, oder?
Die Kokona-Steckdose hat doch nur zwei.
Zwei Schlitze.
Ist das die kanadische Steckdose?
Was ist das für eine Steckdose, Leute?
Oder ist es doch die Kokona-Steckdose?
Es könnte wirklich NA-Steckdose sein.
Die sieht wirklich sehr erschrocken aus, ja?
Ja, ja, es hat wirklich was hier vorne.
US-Steckdose, okay.
Was hat denn hier? Irgendein Kabel-Modem?
Kabel-Modem?
Äh, einige Switche am Start? Steckdosenleisten?
Ähm... keine Ahnung.
Telefon oder so?
Telefonanlage oder sowas? Ich erkenne es jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau.
PoE-Switch?
Gut, nichts allzu spektakuläres.
Das ist, wo alle Ethernet-Kabel von überall um die Haustür konverteriert werden können.
Es gibt tatsächlich ungefähr 40 Waren hier.
Einige Leute haben gefragt, worum es geht.
Na ja, es ist eigentlich nur eine Pipe, die ich bei der Hardware-Store gekauft habe, die sich zusammensetzt.
Aber diese beiden hier bleiben die niedrigeren 100-Megabit-Kabel.
Was wirklich nicht passt.
Das ist ja aus dem letzten Jahr tausend.
Hundert.
Hundert Mbit.
Die sind ja... das ist ja...
...richtig.
Monarch S.
Okay, kommt da noch ein bisschen mehr hier jetzt?
Da kommt aber wenig jetzt.
Ah, jetzt zeigt der irgendwie sein NAS. Okay.
Das ist aber...
Da kann ich gar nicht so viel zu sagen, weil das Setup, was der hat, macht einen wirklich angemessenen Gesamteindruck.
Nicht so die Leute, die...
...drei Racks daheim stehen haben.
Ja okay, dann mecke ich heute nicht über die Hardware anderer Leute.
Ich mach ja gerne über die Hardware anderer Leute mecke.
...
...German-Deutsch.
Ah, das war richtig, richtig schön im Keller.
Oh, alle HP-Kisten, äh...
...das ist aber richtig alt.
Von...
Ach, 2016 ist das Video.
Okay, nee, lass gucken.
Okay, äh, wir können Battlefield Top Plays gucken.
Wir können das hier gucken.
Tour of my Home Network, da haben wir doch noch irgendwas.
Excellent.
Da kann... da kann ich doch noch ein bisschen über Hardware meckern.
Wofür brauche ich ein Smart-Switch? Wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Also Smart-Switch, das Wort gibt's an sich, also...
...wüsste ich nicht, ob das näher definiert ist.
Was du meinst, ist wahrscheinlich ein Switch, den man managen kann.
Also sprich, ähm...
...der vielleicht ein Web-Interface hat, ein Commando-Sign, oder sonst was, wo ich Einstellungen dran vornehmen kann.
Ja, der dann auch sowas wie WLANs kann, oder manche Switche können ja mittlerweile auch, äh...
...IP-mäßig irgendwas...
... äh, Port-Filter machen, oder so.
Die ganzen MikroTik-Switche haben... können... können zum Beispiel, äh...
...IP-Sachen machen.
Auch wenn auch nicht sonderlich schnell, wohlgemerkt.
Das nimmst du... das nimmst du, wenn dir ein normaler Switch nicht reicht.
Zum Beispiel, weil du... weil du WLAN-Settings machen musst, oder...
Ja, ein normaler Unmanaged-Switch, den schließt er halt an, und er switcht.
Und sonst nix, du kannst da dran nix einstellen.
Ja, und die meisten Managed-Switche, der fängt dann an mit, äh...
...WLAN-Geschichten, äh...
...geht weiter, dass du vielleicht noch verschiedene Bridge-Interfaces zusammen pitchst.
Du kannst was auch immer, also...
...Port, äh...
...Aggregation machen, und alle möglichen Sachen.
Also, wenn du sowas machen willst, dann brauchst du nen Switch, mit dem du...
...der managet ist, und der die passenden Features hat.
Willst du das nicht machen, dann brauchst du das auch nicht.
So, wo ist sein Rack? Wow!
Okay!
What the fuck?!
Der willst daheim aber echt wissen, hier mit Glas-Faser-Zeug.
Mein Access-Switch ist ein UniFi-USW-PRO48-D.
Wir hatten unser Bauteil gegründet, und haben eine Dedikate-AV-Klosette...
...auf dem Theater-Radar gelegt.
Es hat sich also auch viel verändert.
Ist das die USV? Nee, was ist das?
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ich fahre jetzt mein ganzes Netzwerk auf Ubiquity-Unit.
Moment, er hatte die hoch... Ey!
EXACT... so...
...hatten wir früher die Switche in unseren Technikräumen auf der Arbeit hängen.
Hochkant. Deswegen haben die damals den Felix und mich immer, also als wir unsere Ausbildung noch gemacht haben...
...haben die immer den Felix und mich in diese Technikräume geschickt...
Weil wir die einzigen zwei waren, die dünn genug waren, damals, dass wir da durchgepasst haben vor den Switches.
Ich meine nur, dass wir halt irgendwie so acht Stück nach vorne hängen hatten und der Raum hier fertig war.
Und wir waren die einzigen, die durchgepasst haben, die anderen waren alle zu dick.
Also, Moment, was hat der für einen?
Ja, das ist der gleiche Switch, den ich habe. Nur das ist, dass ich nicht die Unify-Variante gekauft habe, sondern die Edge-Switch-Variante.
Das ist exakt der gleiche Switch, den ich habe. Nur die Unify-Variante. Guck mal.
Unify ist vorne halt einfach silber und meiner ist schwarz vorne.
Ja. Und das ist der gleiche Switch.
Naja, Max halt die Klappe. Ja.
Exzellent.
Max zeigt den Switch. Max zeigt den Switch.
Ah, der da.
Ah.
Ja, das ist genau der gleiche Switch.
Okay, er hat schon mal gute Switches sich ausgesucht.
Exzellente Switch-Auswahl. Exzellent.
Welches 4HR-Gehäuse? Das ist irgendein Chen-Pro-Chen-Pro-Irgendwas.
Muss, muss, Moment, kann ich dir sagen, es steht ja hier in der Beschreibung drin.
Äh, Gehäuse, Gehäuse, Gehäuse ist das da.
Das ist das Gehäuse.
Und das Gute an dem Gehäuse ist, das kannst du, also du kannst hier Laufwerke reinmachen und hier Laufwerke reinmachen, den Lüfter von da nach da und dann Lüfter komplett raus machen.
Ich hab hier in der Mitte den Noctua-Lüfter reingemacht und das Beste ist, die liefern Staubfilter mit, was nun wirklich für Server-Gehäuse sehr selten ist.
Also ich kenn, ich kenn außerdem, hab ich noch nie ein anderes Server-Gehäuse in der Hand gehabt mit einem Staubfilter.
Noch nie.
Welche Distro benutzt du eigentlich?
Äh, Windows 10.
Okay, ich weiß, dass du das nicht meinst. Ich benutze mal ein Jaro mit i3-WM.
Das ist, wo alles in der Hausplug-Gehäuse ist.
Inkl. PoE-Kameras, Desktop-PCs, TVs, etc.
Ja, gute, gute Switch-Auswahl. Da kann ich das, kann ich so, äh, approven, ja.
Now, anywhere in the house that I need more ports than I have walljacks is a UniFi US60W 8-Port.
Wenn ihr das so seht, vielleicht verstehen die einen oder anderen jetzt auch, warum ich da an sich bin, dass Rundgang im dunklen Rechenzentrum irgendwas Weihnachtliches hat.
Stellt euch mal vor, einen kompletten Raum mit blauen, grünen und roten LEDs, die unterschiedlich blinken.
These are awesome, because not only do they support PoE, but they also are part of the SDN.
Das würde ich nicht mit einem UniFi-Switch machen. Das würde ich wahrscheinlich mit irgendeinem Mikro-Tick-Switch machen.
Allowing me to pass security policy, VLANs, etc., while remote monitoring them via SNMP.
SNMP, 0, Monitoring, YOLO-Style, wer braucht Monitoring, oder?
In the case of my living room, this means I can have my security camera on the secure network and my TV on the regular network.
Ja, das habe ich auch so.
For my firewall, I have replaced the old one with a Supermicro 5018D-FN8T.
This server is designed to be used as a router or firewall appliance and has 12 gigabit ports, 2 SF...
Kann man machen, bin ich mittlerweile von weg. Ich mache das über meinen Mikro-Tick-Router.
Der hat ein paar IP-Filterregel drin, das reicht mir an Firewall. Ganz ehrlich, was braucht man da großartig im Heimbereich?
...P-Plus-Ports for 10 gig...
Einfach verbieten von einem Netz ins andere oder erst gar nicht erlauben.
Und ein paar Blocks, ein paar Block-Regeln für das China-IoT-WLAN.
Ansonsten fertig.
Ich habe insgesamt vielleicht 15 Firewall-Regeln.
Die wichtigste Regel, die man nicht vergessen darf, ist internes Netz ganz oben Allow All, weil ansonsten sperrt man sich manchmal aus.
Lade Sie sich ein, sich zu bewegen.
Ich habe einen ZEON D1518 und 32UB täglich am Internet.
Dieser hat mir schon recht gut gefallen.
Ich habe viele kleine OpenVPN-Sessions verwendet...
...und habe einen VPS 5 Brother-Haus geführt.
Der 8-Bit-Gei
Der Pf-Blocker, der IPF...
... ein IDS für Sicherheit und mehr.
journey
... en das absolut beste Boxen-Programm, das Sie Calibration machen können.
P. K.
Ja, der Twinkor hat vielleicht so was am Start, falls der noch da ist. Kann ich mir vorstellen.
... und habe die IDS auch für Sicherheit und mehr.
Ansonsten, wer braucht ein IDS, also ein Intrusion Detection System, wer braucht denn sowas daheim? Niemand, genau.
Kannst du mal die Regeln für dein IoT-WLAN zeigen? Ne, zeigen kann ich die nicht, aber ich kann sie dir sagen. Ich habe alles geblockt, das sind zwei Regeln, zwei Regeln habe ich drin.
Alles ganz early in der Firewall-Chain, es darf keine Kommunikation stattfinden, außer, und das ist die eine Regel oben drüber, außer...
...ein NTP zur Gateway-IP, weil Zeit sollten sich diese Systeme doch abrufen dürfen. Oh, ein Bit, exzellent.
Ja, total Oversized, total Oversized, brauchen wir nicht.
Ich finde es cool, dass er das gleiche gemacht hat wie bei mir, ne? Ich habe ja auch die fetten Kisten abgeschafft und habe jetzt eine kleine hier stehen.
Das ist...
Wenn man damit anfängt, man startet oftmals total Oversized, bis man dann feststellt, man braucht das alles gar nicht.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt, er hat sogar noch aufgerüstet.
Was machen die alle?
Was haben die alle daheim laufen?
Ich habe jetzt hier eine Low-Power-Intel-Kiste.
Wo das meiste Zeug draufläuft, ja.
Vom, vom, ja, für einen Black-Server, selbst dafür, ne, wo das meiste draufläuft, vom Wiki bis zum Kamera-Zeug, ich habe schon wieder vergessen, was da alles drauf ist.
Alle möglichen Sachen, also das, was ich so täglich brauche, ganz File-Server und sowas, das läuft auf einer ganz billigen Low-Power-Intel-Kiste.
Da habe ich jetzt, ich habe ja so ein Strom-Best-Ding dran.
Dann brauche ich gerade EIDL, Moment, fuck, ich bin mit meinem Stuhl über dem Headset, Moment.
So, jetzt bin ich wieder runter.
Das brauche ich gerade EIDL mit 10G-Karte drin, 11 Watt, so, im Vergleich zu dem fetten 4A-E-Kiste.
Ja, und ansonsten habe ich halt ein paar Raspberry Pis am Start hier.
Octopi für den Drucker, dann die Kamera am Hoftor.
Äh, und auch einige ESP32s rumstehen.
Dann das UniFi-Ding für das WLAN.
Also, ich habe, glaube ich, ein bisschen mehr mittlerweile, weniger Single-Point-of-Failure, mehr Distributed-Zeug.
Und ich fahre besser damit.
Als ich noch meine fette 4A-E-Server-Kiste hatte, da hatte ich ja noch, da ist man, also die hier, ne, wo man hier sieht, da oben die.
Also, da hatte ich ja damals, ist mir noch vorgeschwebt, deswegen habe ich auch so eine Oversight.
Das heißt, äh, 8-Kern-Xeon-Kiste damals gebaut.
Ähm, ist mir ja vorgeschwebt, du machst alles auf diesem Server.
Was von der Idee her auch nicht schlecht war.
Aber irgendwann, und auch wunderbar funktioniert hat.
Und ich konnte da theoretisch sogar mehr mit machen als heute.
Das Problem war nur, dass es mir irgendwann mal eingeleuchtet ist.
Scheiße.
Wenn ich das Ding ausschalte, kann ich nicht mal mehr meine Rollläden hoch und runter machen.
Ja.
So, ganz kurz ab.
So, wieder am Start.
Äh, genau.
Äh, deswegen, wo bin ich gerade stehen geblieben?
Das, deswegen, ich habe es jetzt ein bisschen mehr verteilt da.
Und wie gesagt, die große 4A-E-Kiste, die habe ich immer noch, aber die ist gerade gar nicht mehr an.
Einfach, weil ich festgestellt habe, wenn mir die Kiste abraucht.
Oder wenn ich die ausmache, dann kann ich nicht mal meine Rollläden auf und zu machen, richtig.
Remote, ja.
Und, äh, das wollte ich nicht.
Da ging alles drüber, vom Internet bis zur Fernsehaufnahme, alles einfach, komplett.
Das war.
Äh, äh, technisch eine coole Geschichte, aber an sich viel zu, äh, Single Point of Failure, ja.
Jetzt habe ich für drüben im Wohnzimmer, für Fernsehgedöns, habe ich einen, ähm, AC2, einen O-Droid HC2 stehen.
Das ist so ein, so ein kleiner Single Board Computer, so ein kleiner Single Board Computer, wo man eine Festplatte reinmachen kann.
Darauf läuft ein TV Headend und hat einen Dual Tuner USB, äh, TV Stick drinne.
Das macht Fernseh- und, und Fernsehaufnahmen und, äh, Gedöns.
Dann ist ein Shield TV am Fernseh dran, was die Fernsehaufnahmen abspielt, wo auch die ganzen, äh, Amazon-Apps, Netflix-Geschiss und sonst was drauflaufen.
Ähm, dann habe ich meinen MikroTik-Router für Internet-Routing-Geschichten, die Fritzbox für DECT und, äh, VoIP.
Äh, Octopi am Drucker, äh, paar ESPs für die, äh, verteilter, es ist viel verteilter als früher.
Und es ist der, der bessere Ansatz.
Da bin ich, da bin ich wirklich mittlerweile auch von überzeugt, dass, äh, diese riesen fetten Kisten, die alles machen, nicht,
so, äh, sinnvoll sind, ja.
Welchen Shield TV hast du, die Pro-Variante?
Nee, ich habe auch noch die alte, die, ähm, die hier.
Die hier habe ich noch, guck mal.
Hallo, Jungs und Mädels.
Ja, hier, die alte, äh, warum, ja, ich habe Nvidia-Schuhe, ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich Nvidia-Schuhe habe.
Hier, die, die alte da.
So 2000, was ist denn das, 2017er Modell.
Habe ich noch, wunderbar, ich kann echt, also, man muss sagen, ich hoffe, die stellen das Shield TV nie ein,
weil ich, es ist zwar nicht die, das Billigste, aber ich finde, es ist das Beste, was es gibt.
Gerade auch von App-Unterstützung, das ist wirklich top.
Es gibt mittlerweile sicherlich gute Alternativen, ähm, habe ich mich aber nicht ausreichend mit beschäftigt.
Also wenn man es billig haben will, nimmt man sich einen Firestick, die bloatet.
So.
Was machen die da alle mit?
switch mit redundant 10 gigabit links ich meine es ist es ist technisch sehr
nice ja deswegen habe ich das ja bei mir mittlerweile auch mit zehn gigabit
aber zwei dinge mit mit dual dual 10g da sind schon mal ist immer fast ist ein
drittel der ports am switch weg
das ist voll auf was heißt für daheim aber cool ist es ist aber cool ist es
ist das nicht die ist das nicht die diese telefonzelle
ich guck das nicht das ist doch ist das das ist nicht doch das doch das trip
doctor strange ist da oder wie heißt das leute müssen das ist auch die
telefonzelle aus dieser einen serie doctor who doctor strange
doctor who ist
das okay die idee aus england die serie das sind auch diese telefonzellen
das ist total auf was heißt was macht er denn damit
vmware vmware cluster okay für den vmware cluster lass ich es mir gefallen
ich lasse ich finde es nicht sinnvoll den vmware cluster daheim zu betreiben
aber für den vmware cluster wenn man sich dafür entschieden
man möchte es daheim betreiben dann dann lasse ich mir dieses setup gefallen
das klingt sinnvoll
das hat was
thema
das war
Und dann ein RS-2416 plus NAS mit 24TB Rohrkapazität.
Der 2416 wurde unter Warrantie verwendet, weil der Intel-Atom-Bug war.
Okay, also...
Was läuft an all diesem Hardware?
Als ich das ein bisschen zurückgebaut habe und eher in kleine, autonome, ein bisschen mehr verteiltere Sachen gegangen bin, ist...
Erstens, das sind Sachen, um die musst du dich bei jedem Scheiß selbst kümmern.
Ja, du musst gucken, dass deine Updates funktionieren, dass du es irgendwie aktuell hältst.
Du musst hier...
Also, dieses Setups zu administrieren ist ja quasi kein Tagesjob, aber...
Mal zumindest alle 1-2 Wochen mal...
...einen Wochenendjob, sich da drum zu kümmern.
Oder man lässt es einfach vergammeln und stellt nach 1,5 Jahren fest, fuck, ich kann doch nicht mal mehr ein Update machen, weil irgendwie Repos nicht, was auch immer.
Es ist also Stromverbrauch, die Dinger ziehen ordentlich.
Und das ist das, was man oftmals im Heimbereich unterschätzt, der Administrationsaufwand.
So geil die Sachen sind, wenn man sie initial einrichtet und man seinen Spaß dran hat.
Wenn der Kram irgendwann einfach nur da ist und läuft...
...möchte man, dass die Dinger möglichst unauffällig einfach gehen.
Ja, und laut ist es auch noch.
Deswegen bin ich da wirklich zufrieden mit dem Setup auf dieser Low-Power-Intel-Kiste.
Da ist ein Ubuntu-Server drauf, ich glaube 1804 oder was, schon 20...
Ich glaube sogar...
Nee, mittlerweile 20...
Nee, ich glaube nur 1804 ist da drauf.
Irgendwas Älteres ist da auf jeden Fall drauf.
Und es könnte sogar 20.04 schon sein.
Es könnte sogar 20.04 schon sein.
Ja, und da sind 5, 6 Containersachen drauf.
In einem relativ easy Docker-Compose-File gestartet.
Und da ist, weiß ich nicht, auf DokuWiki, Nextcloud, ein Fileserver.
Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Allein schon dadurch, dass ich das vergessen habe, in der Git-Geschichte...
Allein schon dadurch, dass ich es vergessen habe, spricht dafür, dass es ziemlich problemlos läuft.
Ja.
Und das macht alles automatisch.
Das macht Container-Upgrades, also Anwendungs-Upgrades automatisch innerhalb einer festgelegten Version.
Also sprich, ich habe so eingestellt, dass der Nextcloud nicht einfach eine Major-Version-Update macht,
von sagen wir mal von 19 auf 20, sondern nur 19.01.02.03 meiner Patches,
weil ansonsten gehen dir deine Anwendungen einfach kaputt von heute auf morgen und du weißt nicht warum.
Und das Ganze mit Let's Encrypt-Zertifikaten auch automatisch über DNS-Challenge ausgestellt.
Wohin machst du das?
Das ist...
Das ist einfach Docker-Compose-File.
Das haben wir sogar mal im Stream gemacht.
Und Traffic als Reverse-Proxy davor.
Wobei ich Traffic von der Config her überhaupt nicht mag,
aber in Kombination mit Docker-Gedöns ist das ganz praktisch, weil es viel automatisch machen kann.
Würde ich eine Reverse-Proxy von Hand bauen, würde ich wahrscheinlich ganz klassisch den Nginx nehmen.
Oder aber, wenn es Easy-Config sein soll, Cudi.
Was ist die Telefonzelle aus Docker?
Huuu, habe ich gerade gelernt.
So heißen dem seine Server.
Ja.
Ähm...
Und ich muss sagen, ich fahre damit echt mittlerweile sehr problemlos, ja.
Also...
Umso mehr automatisch.
Das einzige, was mir daheim bei meinem Setup noch fehlt,
wo ich schon lange Zeit am gucken bin,
so eine wirklich minimale Easy-Monitoring-Geschichte.
Ich habe aktuell da einen Grafana laufen mit, ähm...
Prometheus.
Das wollte ich jetzt ein bisschen ausbauen, weil das macht aktuell eigentlich nichts,
außer, äh, Status sammeln von der Heizung im Keller und ein Ping-Check oder so.
Ne, PRTG kann ich nicht machen, das ist Windows.
Ich installiere mir keine Windows-VM da drauf, nur für PRTG.
Plex? Warum machen alle Plex?
Es gibt...
Es gibt doch eigentlich überhaupt keinen Anwendungszweck für Plex.
Im Jahr 2020.
Der einzige Anwend...
Warum...
Ich sage es jeden Stream, warum...
Warum haben so viele Leute Plex?
Plex...
Der einzige...
Die einzige Existenzberechtigung, die mir bisher jemand nennen konnte, für Plex ist,
wenn man ein großes Archiv aus...
Naja, sag mal, entweder illegal runtergeladenen Sachen hat,
oder eben archivierten Blu-Rays und sonst was.
Wenn man ein großes Offline-Archiv an Filmen hat,
und...
Und Medien, die man öfters schaut.
Dafür ist Plex gut.
Aber...
Macht das wirklich jemand?
Also ich guck mal...
Man guckt sich einen Film.
Den guckt man sich vielleicht eins, maximal zweimal an mit ein bisschen Abstand.
Eventuell, wenn es sowas geiles ist wie Matrix, vielleicht auch mit ein paar Jahren Abstand mehrfach.
Aber das brauche ich doch nicht lokal auf einem...
Auf einem Storage-Medium lokal bei sich.
Also sprich, wo ist...
Ich verstehe wirklich legit den Anwendungszweck.
Ich will keinen schlecht machen, der Plex verwendet.
Ich verstehe den Sinn davon.
Lokal nicht.
Data-Horror-Syndrom, ja.
Ich finde es viel angenehmer mittlerweile, Netflix, Prime, den Kram darüber zu streamen,
anstatt den überhaupt lokal für mich die Sachen vorzubehalten.
Natürlich, was man machen kann ist, was ich auch irgendwie nachvollziehen kann,
wenn jemand sagt, okay, sie haben Bedenken, dass Prime und Netflix die Sachen aus dem Programm nehmen
und sie fanden es so geil und wollen es trotzdem behalten.
Ja gut, das sind dann vielleicht...
Wie oft findet man Musik oder Filme so geil,
dass man sie trotzdem auf jeden Fall für immer...
archivieren will, falls sie mal Amazon oder Netflix aufs Programm nehmen?
Es gibt einen Subreddit für Data-Horror, ja klar.
Also, also, das ist eine Sache dafür.
Ihr wisst, ich bin nicht der ordentlichste, guckt euch mal den Desktop an.
Aber da verstehe ich den Anwendungszweck wirklich nicht.
Ja gut, gucken wir mal weiter.
Ah, excellent.
Home-Server kenne ich niemanden, der das verwendet sonst.
Was machen?
Boah.
Windows-Server.
Ich habe sogar eine komplette Kopie von Wikipedia, wenn es um die Zombie-Apokalypse geht.
Okay.
Der macht die Sachen nicht, weil sie sinnvoll sind, sondern weil sie cool sind.
Ey, wenn dem Traum nicht draufkommt, nimm mir eine Wikipedia-Kopie für die Zombie-Apokalypse.
Egal, aber cool.
So, Observium ist eine Monitoring-Geschichte.
Und ich benutze Observium, um alle meine...
Du willst nochmal den Desktop sehen?
Hier, ja, excellent.
...server.
Wie findet ihr eigentlich den Windows-Server-Kack, Veda?
Ist doch gut, oder?
Ich finde den top.
Ich habe vergessen, wer ihn gemacht hat.
Irgendjemand aus dem Stream hat den gemacht.
Excellent.
Ja, stimmt, wenn er einen Zombie-Apokalypse hat, muss er erstmal einen Diesel-Generator für seinen Server anschmeißen.
Wie viel Speicher braucht man denn für Wikipedia?
Nur Text, nicht viel.
Ich hatte damals...
Ich habe das in letzter Zeit nicht mehr gemacht.
Ich hatte damals eine Kopie von Wikipedia auf meinem Nintendo DS.
Text only.
Okay.
Also, ne, Custom Homebrew-Software auf dem DS.
Da gab es einen Wikipedia-Reader für den DS.
Oder dieses Format, was Wikipedia hat.
Es gab wirklich coole Homebrew für den DS damals.
Und ich hatte in der Berufsschule deutsche Wikipedia auf einer Micro-SD-Karte im DS dabei.
Das waren 3-4 Gigabyte.
Allerdings, wir reden hier von Text only.
Wenn das einfach nur...
Ein kompletter Dump ist.
Also wirklich mit Bildern und Beispiel-Videos und sonst was.
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, wie groß, aber es ist wirklich groß.
Da gehe ich mal ganz von aus.
Es ist wirklich ordentlich groß.
Da kommst du nicht mit 5-6 Gigabyte aus.
Wiki im Docker.
Doku-Wiki habe ich bei mir lokal.
Das ist als Docker-Container.
Und hat sich übrigens letztens zerstört.
Weil Versions-Update.
Und ich habe noch Latest drin stehen gehabt.
Generell, wenn ihr Docker-Composer...
... oder irgendwelche Orchestrierungs-Sachen verwendet, mit automatischen Image-Updates,
stellt die Container nicht auf Latest.
Die gehen früher oder später kaputt.
Stellt das auf aktuelle meiner Version und aktuelle Major-Version und dass der meiner Version Updates macht.
On NAS1, I have a 42-Terabyte-Volume that stores all of my Plex-Videos.
Data-Dump-Wikipedia.
Okay, zeig mal her.
Ist wie groß englische Wikipedia?
20?
Sind da auch Bilder dabei und sowas?
Das ist gar nicht so groß.
20G?
Wikipedia-Commons ist auch nur 23 Terabyte.
Geht doch eigentlich.
Gar nicht so wild.
Das geht auch sogar.
Kann man machen.
Übrigens, die gleichen Festpläne habe ich auch.
An der 2. habe ich ein 9-Terabyte-Volume für...
Ich habe extra die 5.000er-Umdrehung gekauft.
Die brauchen nicht so lange zum Anlaufen und viel eher sind die leiser und brauchen weniger Strom.
... die NVR für alle meine Kameras.
Und ein weiteres 9-Terabyte-Volumen für den General-File-Storage und ein Sync-Share für Dropbox.
Okay, also zurück...
Nein.
900 Terabyte Dropbox?
Okay, der ist professionell. Der will es wissen.
... zur Home-Network für eine Minute.
9 Terabyte?
Ordentlich.
Ich werde diesen HD-Homerun-Extend benutzen, um ein analoges Signal an alle meine TVs und Geräte zu distribuieren.
Wieso braucht man so viel Speicher?
Naja, wenn man Filme und so speichern will, ist klar.
Ansonsten, oder wie dieser Typ bei Amazon, der Webcam-Porn-Archiv hatte mit Peter Beid.
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt von dem Typ, der Amazon Unlimited ans Limit gebracht hat?
Der hat Amazon Unlimited Speicherplatz gemietet und hat dann eine Software programmiert, die quasi Porn-Streams, Porn-Webcams, das war Amazon, das war nicht Google, das war ziemlich sicher Amazon, der Porn-Webcams mitschneidet.
Weil, ich meine, der konnte den Kram ja nicht selbst uploaden und hat das dann archiviert auf...
Auf Amazon, äh, diesem Amazon Drive und hatte dann irgendwie Peter Beid, äh, Webcam-Porn.
Und wahrscheinlich hat's auch Amazon aus dem Grund nicht gelöscht, die haben wahrscheinlich selbst geguckt.
Ne, weiß ich nicht.
Ähm, und zumindest seitdem ist, äh, Amazon Unlimited ja auch nicht mehr unlimited.
Ja, dafür braucht man viel Speicher.
Wenn man das nicht hat, ist es erstaunlich, mit wie wenig Speicher man auskommt für die wichtigsten Sachen.
Bei mir ist das, äh, ein Dump, ein aktueller Dump vom...
Äh, vom Handy, von den beiden, von den zwei Smartphones.
Aktueller Dump, äh, das sind dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 6G oder so.
Ähm, jeweils und vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen die letzten zwei, drei Dumps.
So, ein paar bisschen, bisschen, bisschen Backup und die allerwichtigsten Sachen, da komm ich vielleicht, sag mal, auf 20G oder so.
Und da ist, da ist schon auch mehr Sachen drin, als wirklich, die wirklich essentiell wären.
Das, das allerwichtigste eigentlich, was ich gebackupt haben muss, ist meine Passwort-Datenbank.
Damit ich die Sachen auch verwenden kann.
Alles in Zukunft, aber ansonsten.
Ja, kann man machen.
Ja, HomeSeer ist nicht meins, äh, HomeAssist ist das Beste.
Ah, exzellent.
Die sind bei mir auch mittlerweile am Start.
Und die, die sind wirklich...
Die sind wirklich nice.
Ich persönlich denke, dass das die absolut besten Anwendungspunkte sind, die man für ein Zuhause kaufen kann.
Und der hat's richtig gemacht.
Der hat die Dinger an die Decke gehängt, dafür sind die gemacht.
Bei mir liegen sie auf der, äh, auf der anderen Seite.
Und die Dinger sind, äh, wie, also, auch wie die, die Antennen und die Charakteristik, die nachher aufgebaut ist,
die sind dafür gedacht, an die Decke montiert zu werden.
Ich konnte nicht glücklicher sein.
Aber es geht, es geht auch, wenn sie auf dem Bauch liegen.
Ich habe auch die Möglichkeit, dass mir die Anwendungspunkte, die mir auf den Bauch liegen,
die mir die Anwendungspunkte, die mir auf den Bauch liegen,
Ich habe keine Freunde, die mich besuchen, da brauche ich sowas nicht.
Boah!
What the fuck?
Der hat eine Klimaanlage, okay, nicht wirklich, eine Luft, eine Lüftung für seinen Serverraum.
Nicht übel, nicht übel.
Könnte ich hier auch machen, könnte ich hier sogar relativ easy machen, aber es ist unnütz.
Ähm, weil direkt über mir ist, äh, quasi nur noch der Dachboden.
Und vom Dachboden da einen, so einen Ventilations- irgendwie Schachtel, das wäre relativ easy.
Aber es ist komplett, äh, unsinnig, dafür die, für die paar Kisten, die da drin stehen.
Selbst, wie gesagt, selbst im Sommer, bei 38 Grad draußen, wird's da nicht zu warm drin.
Jetzt gehen wir in mein Büro.
Ich nutze mein Mac nicht mehr als Hauptstation.
Ich habe mich einfach mit Apple befestigt und bin zurück in Windows.
Ich leite ein Core i9 mit 64 GB.
Das Setup von dem Typ gefällt mir. Hat der die gleiche Tastatur?
Also ich muss sagen, ähm, nee, der hat nicht die gleiche Tastatur.
Aber fast die gleiche Tastatur.
Also das Setup von dem Kerl finde ich bis jetzt echt nicht verkehrt.
Äh, wir haben sehr viel ähnliche Hardware.
Sofern, also, ich hab viele Hardware.
Ich habe viel weniger Hardware, aber ansonsten gibt's Überschneidungen, ja, sowohl beim Switch als auch hier.
Scheint schon ganz gute Sachen zu haben.
Was finde das Mic dezent platziert?
Wo war das denn?
Wo war da das Mikrofon?
Sein Headset da hinten?
Ich sehe hier kein Mikrofon.
Webcam?
Das ist so dezent platziert, dass man's gar nicht sieht?
Das könnte ich nicht.
RGB-Rechner hinter der, hinter der, ähm,
RGB-Beleuchtung
von hinten an den Monitor. Boah, das wird mich
voll abfalten.
Ja.
Wie der ähnlich aussieht wie bei mir.
Okay, das habe ich nicht.
Boah,
sowas bräuchte ich unbedingt
auch. Ich bastel aktuell,
ich habe so eine Silikonunterlage, wenn ich
was löten muss und so, die bringe ich entweder
runter in die Küche und mache das da
oder ich mache das hier auf dem Schreibtisch.
Sowas brauche ich unbedingt auch noch.
So einen kleinen Basteltisch, wo ich
Sachen drauf löten kann, wo ich Sachen zusammenstecken
kann, wo ich irgendwelche
Controller-Board-Gedöns ausprobieren
kann. Sowas
bräuchte ich hier.
Echt, auch noch.
Nein, brauchen tust du das nicht, du hättest nur gerne.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, also
der hat ein schönes Setup.
Zwar auch ziemlich oversized,
aber trotzdem finde ich ganz nice.
Smart-Logs kommt mir nicht in die Tüte.
Vor allem nicht, also Smart-Logs
im Haus
würde ich mir noch
gefallen.
Wobei ich im Haus eigentlich so gut für nichts
abschließe, aber
ein Smart-Log an die Eingangstür werde
ich, ich will nicht sagen, nie im
Leben, weil das ist immer
noch lang, hoffentlich,
aber kommt mir in nächster Zeit nicht in die
Tüte. Die Dinger sind so unsicher
und es gibt so viele Sicherheitslücken.
...
Okay, das ist
Just-Kokona-Things
sind das wieder.
Da hat ja jeder irgendwie eine Alarmanlage
mit Überwachung und
Selbstschussanlage und
keine Ahnung,
Waffenschrank mit allem
möglichen drin.
Das ist so wieder
Freedom.
...
Im Leben nicht an der Eingangstür.
Im Leben nicht.
Ja, wenn schon, dann so, ja.
Ja, da
da bin ich ja auch
so ein bisschen, also
aktuell
...
Mein, mein super High End Opel Agila steht ja auf der Straße vorm Haus.
Ich hab genug Platz im Hof, aber mein Hoftor geht nicht richtig auf.
Und ich, ich plane, wo wir wieder bei der Persönlichkeitsumfrage vorher wären, ich hab immer 30, 30 Milliarden Sachen im Kopf, die ich machen will, ja, aber das wenigste davon mach ich dann auch wirklich und beziehungsweise komm dazu.
Ich, ich plane schon seit einer Weile oder ich spiele schon seit längerer Zeit mit dem Gedanken, das Hoftor neu zu machen, nämlich ein Hoftor, was man auch nicht so gut findet.
automatisch auf und zu machen kann, weil
hätte ich das,
dann könnte ich auch mit dem Auto in den Hof fahren,
weil der Hof ist groß genug und da könnte ich
sogar in die Garage fahren, wenn ich es mal leer räumen
würde, weil ich meine, dafür ist die
Garage ja nur irgendwo da, ja.
Ich meine, ich habe eine Garage und verwende sie nicht.
Das ist irgendwie ziemlich beknackt eigentlich, ja.
So, und wenn
das funktioniert, dann könnte ich nämlich das Hoftor automatisch
aufmachen, das Garagentor automatisch aufmachen
und ich könnte mir
vielleicht sogar, wenn der
Agila mal den Geist aufgibt, ich meine, der ist auch
schon 13 Jahre alt oder so, oder älter,
älter wahrscheinlich, ist ganz wein alt auf jeden Fall,
könnte ich mir auch ein Elektroauto kaufen.
Für meine kleinen Furzstrecken wäre das gar nicht so
schlecht.
Alexa kommt mir auch nicht in die Tüte.
Wo hat er, wo hat er
seine, wo hat er, der, der Kerl ist so
upgraded, der hat bestimmt auch
ein paar Staubsaugerroboter.
Okay, so I'm going to address the most
common questions that I got from the 2017
video. Hopefully they'll
apply to this video as well.
So, the first one is, um,
why is your cable management so bad?
Ist es nicht.
Die Leute haben noch nie schlechtes Cable Management
gesehen, das ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
People are confusing the lab
portion of my network. Das ist, das
ist doch absolut,
in Ordnung. Was willst du denn?
Du erkennst doch, du kannst hier noch ohne
Probleme erkennen, wo was hingeht.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt für super
Ordnungsliebhaber, hier oben
hat er übrigens einen C-Wave,
einen C-Wave Bewegungssensor, den gleichen habe ich
auch draußen hängen.
Aber das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Das ist doch, das ist absolut
in Ordnung. Du kannst das hier ohne
Probleme nachvollziehen,
wo was hingeht.
Ich würde mal sagen, die Glasfaserkabel,
falls das hier unten die Glasfaserkabel sind, sind die
vielleicht,
ein bisschen eng
gerollt.
Muss man ein bisschen aufpassen, wobei, geht eigentlich.
Aber ansonsten ist es in Ordnung.
Man muss immer gucken,
vom Aufwand zu dem, was man von rauskommt.
Also hat man wirklich was davon,
wenn es wie geleckt aussieht,
wenn man dafür,
zwei Monate extra Zeit braucht
und bei jeder Wartungsarbeit
zwei Stunden extra braucht, weil man nicht richtig
dran kommt?
Da muss man sich immer fragen.
Richtig, genau so ist es, Leute.
Genau so wie er es sagt.
Gibt es heute Barbecue-Pitboys?
Wir können tatsächlich gleich was gucken, weil ich habe übelst Hunger
und muss was essen.
Zum Beispiel Schokolade, die wir jetzt hier auch besitzen.
Und ich habe die Badegasse dabei.
Die ist jetzt sogar noch nicht um das Ziel gegangen
zu kommen.
Wir werden sie jetzt nochmal aus der Teile aufeinandern.
Da haben wir ja schon ein paar Knochen.
Also ich bin ein bisschen zu aufgeregt,
damit wir das hier mal kurz zeigen.
Und die Badegasse gilt für es.
Und die kommt aus dem Verlauf.
Das ist natürlich genau das, was wir hier werden.
Das ist die Hände von deinem Server-Kloset.
Also es ist wirklich eine Hände-Handknappe.
Und der hat einfach mit dieser Hände,
diese Badegasse, die die Hände hier auf das Buch
rein gelegt.
So, da haben wir uns hier angefangen.
Und das ist ein ganz interessantes Thema.
Das ist auch so eine typische
Ami-Geschichte, das habe ich hier noch nie gesehen.
Diese
Aufhäng-Holzdinger.
An sich finde ich,
das ist eine richtig coole Sache.
Habe ich aber so noch nie gesehen.
Im Optimalfall macht gutes
Kabelmanagement es für die komplette Lebenszeit.
Das ist richtig, da gebe ich dir voll und ganz recht.
Aber für viele Leute ist
gutes Kabelmanagement nur gutes Kabel,
wenn du die Kabel nicht mehr siehst.
Das ist dann quasi
eher so der,
darf man ja nicht mehr sagen,
früher hat man dazu gesagt,
der Waff, quasi so der
Woman-Acceptance-Faktor.
Das ist ja
verpönt mittlerweile, sowas zu sagen.
Zumindest, dass es dann
optisch halt über
technische Notwendigkeit hinaus
sauber, ordentlich macht.
Also wenn man
gutes Kabelmanagement hat,
dass man halt,
dass die Kabel nicht im Weg hängen,
wenn man einen Server rauszieht und sowas,
vollkommen okay.
Wenn man aber halt anfängt,
dass man die Kabel quasi aktiv versteckt,
weil du Leute hast, die sagen,
oh, ich sehe ein Kabel,
das sieht ja ganz grausam aus,
dann macht es halt schon keinen Sinn mehr.
Das ist halt so ein bisschen,
das ist auch ein bisschen,
ich glaube, ich mache mir auch so ein Brett an die Wand.
Eigentlich eine richtig geile Idee.
Ich mache mir auch so ein Brett an die Wand.
Guck mal, ich mache mir einfach hier ein Brett an die Wand.
Da, hier kommt ein Brett an die Wand.
Und an das Brett mache ich den ganzen Kram,
der nicht 19 Zoll Bauweise ist.
Ich mache mir hier ein Brett hin,
oder vielleicht sogar oben drüber hier,
mache ich mir ein Brett hin,
und an das Brett kommt dann die Fritzbox,
dieser alte TP-Link-Switch.
Da kommt alles dran,
was nicht 19 Zoll ist.
Dieser ganze Müll hier,
den gibt es übrigens gar nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, ich mache mir einfach auch ein Brett.
Einfach ein Brett an die Wand.
Brett vom Kopf, Brett an die Wand.
Exzellent.
Und dann kommt ReactOS drauf, oje.
Paintschamp, ja.
Wann kommt der Tesla?
Gar nicht.
Ich fahre so wenig Auto,
also wahrscheinlich geht mein Auto eh nicht kaputt.
Und wenn es kaputt geht, ist es schon kaputt.
Ich merke es nicht, weil ich so wenig benutze.
Und Tesla, wozu?
Ich fahre so gut wie gar kein Auto.
Ich würde mir wahrscheinlich irgend so ein kleines Elektroauto,
also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
wenn der Agila kaputt geht,
dann kaufe ich mir ein Elektroauto.
Aber wahrscheinlich irgendwas so kleines,
genauso klein wie das jetzt.
Hackermans.
Ein ONT oder Optical Network Terminal
mit einem Router oder Feuerwall.
Ein ONT ist etwas, das von der Telco oder der ISP erhältlich ist.
Es wird meistens von Fiber zu der Haube installiert.
Oh, ein Renault Zoe.
Da kriege ich endlich mal hier ein Baguette-Auto.
Exzellent.
Mir ist egal, wo das Auto herkommt,
hauptsache es taugt und ist klein und billig.
Das ist das, was wir hier haben.
Also in diesem Fall,
installiert die Telco dieses ONT
auf der Seite deines Hauses in den meisten Fällen.
Obwohl sie es letztens in den Garage und unsere Installierung
gelegt haben, aber das ist, weil ich sie gefragt habe,
es zu machen.
Das ist das, was wir hier haben.
Was? Ich blicke nicht durch.
Was will er?
Ach, das ist der Router von seinem Telefonanbieter.
Ah.
Siehst du?
Was ist das?
Man sieht blankes Kupfer von Kabel.
Das ist in der Regel nie gut.
Aber vielleicht ist es nicht wild.
Ja, dann ist es nicht so wild.
Dann ist es nicht so wild.
Aber normalerweise ist blankes Kupfer an Kabeln
eh nicht gut.
Egal, was es ist.
Diebstahlschutz.
Wenn er da drangreift, kriegt er Elektroschock.
Ja, das könnte man auch so machen.
Das ist so die Kokona-Variante.
Quasi irgendwo von irgendeinem Mast
kommt das Glasfaserkabel runter
und geht dann von hier weiter,
wo er dann letztendlich sein Gerät dran anschließt.
Das ist quasi so der Endpunkt
von der Provider-Glasfaser-Geschichte hier.
Ich glaube, es ist RG6 für Coax, für Kabel-TV
und über die Standard-Potz-Line für Telefon-Service.
Und so ist das alles ihr Gerät
und ich habe keine Kontrolle darüber
und das ist der Grund, warum es auf der Außenseite des Hauses montiert wurde.
Es ist nicht mein Feuerwall oder mein Router.
Okay, also nächstes Mal.
Alexa ist nur ein Spion-Gerät in deinem Haus
und sie hören alles, was du sagst.
Es ist lustig für mich, dass Leute so berührt sind
über mein Alexa, was ich sage,
aber sie scheinen nicht so viel zu kümmern,
was sie über das Telefon, das sie in ihrem Pocket tragen,
was mit dem Internet verbunden ist, egal wo sie gehen.
Und gerade, wenn ich daheim bin,
wo ich private Sachen mache,
da will ich besonders nicht,
dass dort irgendein Amazon-Gerät steht.
Ich glaube, dass Amazon nicht wirklich mutwillig
da jetzt irgendwelche Spionagesachen am Start hat,
einfach nur um zu spionieren,
aber es gab genug Berichte darüber,
dass Amazon-Mitarbeiter sich Aufnahmen,
angehört haben.
Sie sagen natürlich, das ist dafür, um den Service zu verbessern.
Das glaube ich denen sogar bis zu einem gewissen Teil,
aber ob das alles ist, man weiß es nicht.
Die technische Möglichkeit dazu besteht ohne Frage.
Und für mich hat sich der Mehrwert von Sprachsteuerung
auch noch nicht so richtig rausgestellt,
muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Also alles, was ich irgendwie meinem Smartphone sagen könnte,
habe ich verstanden.
Ich habe es wahrscheinlich schneller angetippt.
Und am Rechner erst recht.
Am Desktop hat es überhaupt keine Lasernsberechtigung.
Wo ich den Einsatz von Sprachsteuerung verstehe, ist im Auto.
Im Auto, wenn du unterwegs irgendwelche Sachen machen willst, bedienen,
dann ist Sprachsteuerung super.
Also wenn ich das Handy im Auto verwenden würde,
dann würde ich auch mal einstellen.
Aber ansonsten, große Bereicherung sehe ich da jetzt erstmal nicht.
Naja, das würde natürlich dann Thunis in Power sagen.
Man kann auf Amazon einsehen, was Alexa aufnimmt.
Ja klar, kann man machen.
Das setzt natürlich voraus, dass Amazon dir auch alles anzeigt.
In dem Fall ist es vollkommen egal.
Es muss jeder selbst wissen, ob er sich sowas daheim hinstellen wird.
Aber es muss aber auch jedem klar sein,
dass natürlich die technischen Voraussetzungen dadurch geschaffen werden,
dass man was anstellt.
Dass man was aufnehmen kann.
Ob sie es jetzt machen oder nicht, sei mal dahingestellt.
Viele Leute haben damit überhaupt kein Problem.
Aber ich verstehe auch jeden, der das nicht haben will.
Also ich will es auch nicht haben.
Und wenn man damit kein Problem hat, ist doch in Ordnung.
Kann man machen.
Ich sage ja keinem, er soll kein Alexa sich hinstellen.
Ich stelle mir aktuell kein Alexa hin.
Das liegt unter anderem, also hauptsächlich daran,
weil der Mehrwert übersteigt bei mir noch nicht,
meine Skepsis gegenüber einem Mikrofon in meiner Wohnung.
Und das Ganze trifft übrigens genauso auf Siri, Cortana und Google zu.
Wenn einem sonst nichts mehr einfällt, dann der Aluhut.
Was?
Moment, was?
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Das glaube ich auch nicht.
Aber es gibt garantiert Hardware, da ist das so.
Bei Super Mikro glaube ich es auch nicht.
Aber bei der 0815 China Cloud Kamera, da nicht vielleicht absichtliches Spying in Form von
wir observieren jetzt alles und schicken es an die chinesische Regierung.
Aber das ist teilweise so unsicher und es gibt genug Suchmaschinen im Internet,
wo man sich offene Kameras angucken kann.
Da sieht man, dass das einfach die Realität ist, dass diese Dinger oftmals ungesichert,
unsinnigerweise über das Internet erreichbar sind.
Und vielleicht erinnert sich noch der eine oder andere an diese Wisecam Scandal, ich
weiß nicht, wie man es nennen soll.
Die hatten auch das Problem, dass sie gesagt haben, okay, wir müssen eure Videostreams
nach China schicken und im Endeffekt ist dann rausgekommen, also es war natürlich alles
super sicher, verschlüsselt und bla bla bla, warum sie nach China schicken mussten, lag
einfach daran, vermute ich mal, weil die Closed Source Teile von der Firmware eben so
nicht änderbar waren, dass sie das machen und letztendlich kamen die Streams auf einem
ungesicherten China Server raus und das haben Leute festgestellt.
Und sie hatten so...
Also, das hat nichts mit Aluhut zu tun, das ist Fakt.
Ja, das sieht man auch.
Das kann sich jeder, es wurden ja schon ein paar Links im Chat, das kann sich auch jeder
davon überzeugen, dass das so ist.
Also, das ist noch nicht mal Mut, dem würde ich nicht mal Mutwilligkeit unterstellen,
dass die Anwender sagen, wir spionieren jetzt für die chinesische Regierung, aber die Dinger
sind nun mal an vielen Stellen so unsicher, dass sie über das Internet erreichbar sind.
Und da muss man kein Aluhut für aufziehen, weil es ist halt so, das kann man sich angucken,
das hat nichts mit Verschwörungstheorie zu tun.
Was auch der Grund ist, warum alle meine China-Geräte, selbst die geflashten, in einem eigenen WLAN
für IoT-Geräte sind und dort ist das Einzige, was erlaubt ist, NTP zum Router.
Fertig, mehr gibt's nicht.
Noch nicht mal NTP nach außen, da könnte man ja theoretisch irgendwas drüber tunneln,
einfach NTP zum Router, mehr dürfen die Geräte nicht.
Ja, das stimmt, da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht, natürlich kommen die Sachen
oftmals auch aus praktischen Gründen, weil die Einrichtung einfacher ist.
Zum Beispiel, wer mal irgendwie so eine Xiaomi-Kamera oder sowas eingerichtet hat,
oder eine, das ist ja hier diese Yi-Kamera, das ist ja der gleiche Kram, das ist ja alles
der gleiche Laden irgendwie, die sind halt total einfach einzurichten, deswegen so beliebt.
Das nimmst du, die Kamera, du nimmst dir die offizielle China-App, drückst Setup aus,
hältst dein Handy vor die Kamera mit einem QR-Code, die spricht man tatsächlich Xiaomi aus,
hältst das mit einem QR-Code vor die Kamera und die Kamera richtet sich ein.
Was dazu natürlich notwendig ist, was vielen Leuten nicht einleuchtet ist,
das Ding muss irgendwie deine WLAN-Credentials übertragen.
So, und das macht's wahrscheinlich über den QR-Code.
Aber der QR-Code muss ja irgendwo generiert werden.
Also sprich, deine WLAN-Credentials sind in dem QR-Code generiert.
Jetzt ist die Frage, wird das in der Cloud in China generiert, dein QR-Code?
Wird das lokal auf dem Gerät?
Xiaomi, Xiaomi, Xiaomi, Xiaomi, das kommt doch aufs Gleiche raus.
Weiß man nicht, ja, also allein schon, weil man da seine WLAN-Credentials über irgendeine China-App hat,
die durchaus auch mal in der China-Cloud landen können,
allein schon aus dem Grund wäre ich da skeptisch.
Und das machen die, weil die Einrichtung einfach ist.
Das ist ja auch super einfach.
Du machst die App aus, Setup, Setup, weiter, hältst den QR-Code hin und es geht.
Das ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum ich meine ESPs, also meine Controller,
nicht einfach wegschmeiße, sondern erstmal kaputt mache.
Also die ESP32 mit WLAN-Passwörtern zumindest in der Firmware,
wenn ich die wegschmeiße, will ich sie eh nicht mehr verwenden, dann mache ich die erstmal kaputt.
Ja, es wird wahrscheinlich niemand an meinen Müll gehen,
einen ESP rausholen und die Firmware dumpen und mein WLAN-Passwort rausziehen.
Ja, davon auszugehen, dass das Standard wäre, das ist tatsächlich schon im Bereich der Verschwörungstheorie,
aber warum sollte man die Sache nicht einfach von vornherein ausschließen,
indem man das Ding einfach klein macht, indem man das Ding so weit wie möglich in Stücke zerlegt, ja.
Da wollte ich mir übrigens schon mal einen Shredder für kaufen, habe ich nicht gemacht, ja.
Ähm, äh, Chip, irgendwie Mini-Elektronik-Shredder.
So, so, so einen kleinen, kleinen Scheiß wollte ich mir mal kaufen, habe ich aber nie gemacht.
Ne, ne, nicht sowas, da gibt's, ich, wie hieß der Kram, äh, gehen die ESPs so häufig kaputt?
Nö, nö, aber ich hab schon, also die gehen nicht kaputt, aber ich hab schon ein paar kaputt gemacht, ja.
Sei das, sei das durch zu viel, zu, über, Überspannung am Input oder draufgetreten aus Versehen oder,
oder hier bei dem einen ist jetzt der Knopf kaputt und so.
Manchmal muss man die doch wegschmeißen.
Hast du dir mal so krasse Videos von den Festplatten-Wiederherstellungen gesehen?
Okay, aber ich weiß, dass da einiges geht.
Festplatten ist heute aber eh schwierig, ne.
Also Festplatten sind, gerade bei den neuen Festplatten, wo die Daten auch noch überlagert gespeichert werden,
wenn du da mal überschreibst, kannst du die tatsächlich bedenkenlos wegschmeißen.
Das recovered keiner so easy.
Ja, viel, viel passiert da nicht, die Dinger rauchen halt kurz ab und gut ist.
Ja, jetzt übertreibt man nicht, der Aluhut, Mann.
Ja, weil ihm die Software gefällt, ist doch klar.
So, Leute, ich hab Hunger.
Wir sind heute nicht so weit gekommen mit Videos, irgendwie.
Wollen wir, Leute, wollen wir uns noch was zu essen angucken?
Wollen wir noch, wollen wir uns noch zusammen, ich hab, ich hab übelst Hunger, ich muss jetzt was zu essen holen.
Wollen wir noch irgendwas, irgendwas zu, zu, zu futtern?
Irgend, irgendein Essen, Essen-Video?
Ich hab Hunger.
Gucken wir uns das jetzt mal an.
Das Lego, das Lego-Tank.
Okay.
Ne, der baut jetzt fünf Videos ohne Sound oder alles.
Also, wir brauchen ein ordentliches Essen-Video.
Vor, after.
Oh, in zwei Stunden, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Was Klaus grillt.
Seriously, um vier, ja, da bin ich, da bin ich wirklich gespannt drauf.
Bacon-wrapped Burger-Hotdogs.
Nee, Burger'n'Dogs.
Wollen wir mal sehen, wie das Klaus grillt.
Ist das Barbecue Pit Boys auf Deutsch oder was?
Das kenn ich von 2011, ja.
Ähm.
Grillen im Angelcamp, oh nee.
Geh mal fort.
Was hier, wir gucken jetzt, wir gucken jetzt.
Oh, fuck, ist das laut, oder?
Nee, Leute, ich muss ihn, ich, ich kann, ich kann nicht in Ruhe futtern im Livestream, das funktioniert nicht.
Ich hab das jetzt ein paar Mal probiert.
Wir lassen das jetzt mit Essen.
Ich hab's ein paar Mal probiert im Livestream.
Äh, ich kann nicht.
Ich kann nicht in Ruhe gechillt futtern, während ich hier am, am Mikrofon, das klappt nicht.
Ich hab's ein paar Mal probiert, das, das haut nicht hin.
Ähm, ich speichere mir den Kram mal.
Für nächsten Stream.
Bookmark Tabs.
Session, so, was haben wir denn heute?
Ähm, 06.
09.
Save.
So, und jetzt haben wir hier die übrig gebliebenen Sachen.
Exzellent.
Wieso Serious Sam 4 spielen, äh, streamen, nee.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wie kommt denn das raus?
Genau, das kommt doch jetzt irgendwo.
Ach, 24. September.
Okay.
Na gut.
Ja, das Amazon MMO hatte jetzt letztens erst, äh, Alpha.
Und, äh, die Leute waren ja echt begeistert von, hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
So.
Gucken wir mal, ob ich nicht irgendwelche Subs oder Dinger übersehen hab.
Ich scroll mal schnell drüber, so weit wie's hochgeht.
Aber ich glaube, ich hab nix übersehen.
Ne, sieht nicht so aus.
Oh, doch hab ich was, vorhin hab ich was übersehen.
I am Jinx.
LOL.
Zwei Monate.
Dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription.
Oder hab ich doch vorgelesen?
Subskriber.
Ich bin jetzt gar nicht so sicher.
Wo ich bei Serious Sam immer dran denken muss ist,
Aaaaaaaaaaah.
Ihr wisst was ich mein.
Die, die es gespielt haben, die wissen was ich mein.
Das ungefähr hat's das angehört.
Sound.
Genau das.
Okay Leute, wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Ich hoffe, dass ich die nächste Woche ein bisschen mehr streame.
Ich hab jetzt ziemlich viel daheim rumgebastelt.
Die letzten zwei Wochen.
Ich war eigentlich nur , nur Samstags und Montags bisschen on.
Guck mal, vielleicht krieg ich das die Woche hin, dass ich Éh wieder ein bisschen,
bisschen öfters am Start bin.
Daher kommt der n nickname.
Ach so.
Jetzt ergibt das alles Sinn.
Okay, jetzt merke ich mir für nächstes Mal, wie gesagt, ich laber gern zu Hardware-Videos
von anderen Leuten.
Also macht's gut.
Wir sehen uns, bis denn, see you!